[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
don't got me right
see there we go there we go what about
now hustle how's my mic check now how we
doing
appreciate you also that was loved that
was love professional podcasting
no doubt black conflict x what up nobody
175 what's going on you know what I'm
saying Oh Mr ordinary what's up what's
up you know doubt Michael Welter good to
see you what's going on Salute yeah yeah
ray gun coming in we running a little
late you know what I'm saying because I
just came off another show I'm gonna get
everything set up the Lords are coming
through Chris Ray guy and I spoke to him
he coming through so it's gonna be fun
we got some fun today so uh I will be
back and uh we'll get the rest of these
amazing panel people in here Tom what's
going on it's slowly salute about
Supremacy what up y'all pull it up
before I belong I see y'all I see y'all
that's what's up so look I'll be back
I'm gonna go get some people and uh
we'll have some fun and around fun show
fun topics I will talk to y'all
[Music]
thank you
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up into
your apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
you with messaging people don't aim
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is the Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Arsen up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social lower my city but I'm still
by Coastal I got you
[Music]
thank you
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
whoo
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
damn
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and hell is be swearing ain't
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call it department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
it regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter social knowing my city
but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
oh
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be using
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting the rains you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start with regardless back when you
was messaging people don't aim check my
vocals all on Twitter but a Manti social
or my city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's who
let's do that again
hear you hear me man welcome to the show
if you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all that good stuff that we
need to do in um you know we're about to
get started I am well it's not important
who I am uh what's important is that you
are pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call it department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
[Music]
three radio
I'ma just chill and watch them and he
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young wolf
but then they will mistake me for addict
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like Cyrus you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by King David
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental was an avatar to a knee
Bender I gotta be me though I know it's
my destiny work to cry Nido who cares if
he flies you stealing mosquito you swear
you ain't nothing but really be Stevo
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but I got bad news even if he
really was that dude can you never still
be the king of the statue sister
juvenile I've been cursed with a curse
to be Musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in The Crucible other than nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this
and you're cubicle on the Lord then
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's Day
[Music]
all right switching over let's get a
couple mic checks right quick
hello I'm hearing a lot of yawning today
it's that hour man yeah
that's losing sleep has people you guys
are lucky you getting a yawn from me in
the bushes
I told me I was like oh my God
I woke up at 11 45 at 12 45 I'm like it
can't be done
all right we good we good here you hear
you and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 295 295
y'all
we've been podcasting a lot it's my last
episode
oh glorious and it's another glorious
Sunday we're back at the round table on
the Lord's date I'm extremely excited
about our special guest and we've got
starfield's new release date in
Starfield direct work
your work all right all right Lodi Lux
last Glorious Day Glorious Day Last of
Us factions on PS4 Resident Evil 4
remake demo and EXO Primal and Guilty
Gear strive or Game Pass to discuss so
we're gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a lord who's
charismatic and analytical approach to
the games industry is truly a joy to
listen to whether it be his passion for
all things pop culture or stepping in
the ring to throw them hands for real
all done with this trademark wit and
sarcasm
introducing the comedian and host of the
Chris ray gun YouTube and twitch Channel
co-host of the snark tank and the sacred
symbols PlayStation podcast
my fellow Lord of Destiny and last Dan
Brethren so let me get this straight
Halo 3 is his goal his most overrated
game is a fireable offense on sacred and
he refuses to bump Imagine Dragons
by way of New York and making his day
debut into the realm of the Lords my man
Lord Chris Reagan how are we doing sir
holy hell
that is one hell of an intro man I mean
I'm doing well I I look man I'm honestly
[__] upset
you got it out you got it out
of the front we lost we lost yeah we
lost that hour we lost it out last night
we lost that hour last night and I
thought we were gonna gain one and so I
was out last night and it was it was a
mess
I was like oh no this is not bro I'm not
good it's not good like you said we said
in the pre-show like when that clock
went from like one to three and I'm like
yeah it was not not ideal right what you
been playing man what you been up to
besides that besides losing sleep oh my
God training getting punched in the head
every single like constantly every uh
constantly every week multiple times a
week week multiple times a day it's nice
I think it's probably why I've been
enjoying Destiny so much you gotta talk
about that if you have a concussion is
so good that's a good that's a great
answer I I buy that answer yeah it's
like you know what like that was a weird
campaign but you know what it's not it's
not getting punched in the head so
oh kick do you have any uh training tips
for the young Spar or the young
squabbler that's about to step in the
room is he MMA or he's boxing no boxer
this is yours oh good so did you see the
fight last night with Tony Harrison
versus Tim too last last night no I
didn't I didn't see the fight
but no no no last night he's really
Boston he's not watching
uh Tony Harrison versus Tim Zoo last
night it was a really good fight so if
you want to get any tips you can
actually watch Tim Zoo because he was
underrated going into the fight we
thought Tony Harrison because of his uh
background and his pedigree to give Tim
Zoo a fight but uh in the ninth round
the brakes off of Tony Harrison and left
them slumped in the corner yo Don cicar
you wild disrespectful he said you need
a concussion to play Destiny right now
you're going to stop being disrespectful
I buy that thank you I'm gonna read it
as a superstar
don't do that leave him alone he like
destiny
I was down and you already know we got
the Four Horsemen of gaming those
original Lords of the realm here at the
round table my co-host with the co-host
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his
whole world and the how of the young
wolf my man Lord attic how we do it sir
doing pretty good I played a lot of that
residue before them uh system on that
game it's kind of crazy like yeah we
gotta talk about it it's insane how they
like add one little feature like that
and it completely changed the whole
aspect of the game yeah that little
animation we're gonna talk when we get
to the topic but yes it's interesting so
just been the uh the demo sir
yeah that and Destiny no doubt no doubt
oh shout out to blaze 4K in the building
PlayStation in the building
oh my God he's back here yeah
I had him running let's have a baby okay
you gotta give him a Saudi baby you
gotta give one baby
[Laughter]
in a minute salute The Blaze down so
that's been the Attic
yeah it's pretty much been about it I've
I've been you know watching more
more like TV and stuff this week than I
was gaming besides Destiny no doubt yeah
I've been watching season two of Chucky
no but my I know people like to joke
because Chucky got a TV show but that's
a good TV show like Chucky
Chuck Columbia
I'm not even trying to do that that's
like Jason that Jason hour no no it's
actually a good TV show they got like
people like it's like an extension of
the of the movies and like they did it
right they did it right like the the
little kid Andy from the first one the
one that he tries to to put a solo to
like the all of them like oh really it's
a grown adult is it the actual actor
that'd be cool I don't know if it's the
actual actor I mean it's been a minute
we might not have to check at it addict
just like slasher yeah everything is
murdered killer everything with him is
like severe violence
and then he got the Pico attic on here
Pico addict mode today you gotta be
careful man
foreign
I'm sorry I ain't driving
sir
yeah that's it yeah I did watch Scream
uh definitely watch r r uh this Tuesday
yes sir watch that yeah I can tell you
he can tell you about the murder and I
can tell you about the other movies
and of course we have our most tactical
gaming Lord the solo gamer who lives
with a single player selfish experience
and also that's ostradamus the Lord of
clarity and Lord patreon of the iron
bank my man Lord Sovereign how are we
doing sir I'm doing well I'm doing very
well yeah it is a little bit of an
addendum to my uh intro
can you insert Haley hailing wet from
the mouth someone in the chat said it is
the same character uh it is the same
actor that's cool all right so now we
heal it for the master base
I'm going to preface everything that I
say with hailing from the matter
Lord steam deck over here call him Lord
download
that's fine but you know that that 40 90
rocking baby
girl how's Spider-Man doing anyway no no
Spider-Man are we still the Porsche
still messed up actually no I have to
download it again because I just took it
off the computer because it was just
wait spider wait what are you Spider-Man
was broken so for whatever reason right
I have uh I have a 40 90 laptop right
whatever the reason Flex for whatever
reason is having issues with with the
new multi-core CPUs so it goes in it
automatically picks it once you know for
whatever reason and it like I go in and
it allows me to go like Max all the way
right and then when I go into play it's
it's a slideshow and I'm like what the
hell and I messed around with the
settings I brought it all the way down
below and it still does it Spider-Man is
the new crisis and you really can't
handle it that's just it
sitting in the corner like yeah I'm
sorry all this troubleshoot gaming man
listen man just cause you guys are peons
gotta have the doctors to play that [__]
you know it's gonna be fun day today a
40 90 on a laptop is such tremendous
Overkill it absolutely is but hey if I
got a 40 90 desktop it would be
collected
just put that in your room and crack
that on high I needed something that's
you know relatively portable I say
relatively because it's like a eight
pound yes yeah and I know that power
brick is crazy the power breaker is as
big as a steam deck so yeah old child oh
my God Jesus yeah I wouldn't need that
that to preface everything it's gonna be
funny when you know newcomers to the
show like this guy keeps talking about
the master race what is that
they don't curse but they sure are
racist yeah very elitist
the same thing is the guy that keeps
saying Master race looks like a Puerto
Rican I don't understand that yeah but
it wasn't a building salute to both of
y'all so yeah I was playing uh re4 demo
I played a lot of that nice nice I was
kind of back and forth with I should
then I said you know what it's just the
village part I really do want to see
what's good with this so I played it
enjoyed it as well we'll talk about that
no doubt downloaded Guilty Gear strive
on Game Pass sir I didn't get it I never
got it I was gonna get it on PlayStation
that was like but the same thing I was
like that's around the time where I
really realized that
it doesn't pay for me to buy a lot of
games on Console because I'm not going
to get a chance to play them so I said
nah I didn't let me not do it so it
could be the Game Pass now on the PC bro
who did that for you yeah shout out
shout out to Art system works
he give your business no credit it's
nice he don't have to get my man he just
snatches it but but it was that yo that
game is wow it's pretty that is
interesting yeah it's kind of it's it
has almost two but you know when you saw
Street Fighter 3 for the first time
you're like this has too much animation
um
no they're supposed to the people who
made um
Dragon Ball Fighters yeah they're
they're supposedly making like a my hero
one I might try the fighting scene from
my hero game you know especially some
dark Deku going on okay okay
you don't mess with the fighting games
at all no I don't yeah
they might start breaking out in the
hives if I keep talking about them
there's so many good ones though yeah so
many there's a lot so speaking of
fighting games I I got back I said all
this uh Mortal Kombat talk I said you
know what I gotta get back into MK I
never really played 11. living my life
this week
MK 11 ultimate on a Game Pass yeah who
did that for you
yeah
all the credit for every game pass
Edition it's like yeah he gonna get the
smoke but he get the credit
dominance Maximus Aurelius it's like
it's like and it's like Xbox wants to
bring you every fighter Under the Sun
but Killer Instinct too shots
what he did go over there and play you
could go downloading this in Game Pass
continue yourself I never really played
it when it launched and I saw you know
whatever it's like at kind of every
three Mortal Kombats they sort of
rebooted so 9 10 11 was was this new
reboot right story wise it's kind of
crazy but I had not touched 11 at Austin
let me get into this story bro
this game
it is something else when it comes to
the story when it comes to onboarding
new players and tutorials when it comes
to just hearkening back to the original
trilogy and all the fan service they do
in that regard the Crypt unto itself is
like a game unto itself like it's kind
of Bonkers man and I'm going through the
story mode I'm like is it me or is this
the best Mortal Kombat movie ever made
delicious I've been telling people like
you know how we I'm checking hardcore
and I was always listening like that
ticket even had a narrative and endings
and all of that like Mortal Kombat
doesn't laughed everybody as far as
fighting game having a story for each
person having a character and then you
play as everyone from different
perspectives and it's crazy and it makes
me super excited for 12 because 12 I I
got to put the end got spoiled for me
but I'm not going to spoiled it here but
it ends in a place where you could
basically reset everything right did you
what 12 is you have to do the Aftermath
DLC yes I have to do that you have to do
the like it is so well done and the game
narratively wise go somewhere else that
you could be like yo they doing that
okay yeah it was crazy it's like I feel
like Mortal Kombat has so much potential
like on like TV wise and stuff it's a
shame that like people keep getting
their hands on that brand and just doing
it dirty when it comes oh that last one
yeah
if you're offended by the movies just
play the game story mode and you'll be
fine you're like really it's that good
and the last fighting game thing is we
got that last trailer for one of my
former men's and Tekken now I'm a little
disappointed because yeah I'm not about
the hair I don't know it's like midlife
crisis
I liked him when he was like hitting his
30s where he had the ponytail and got
the beard almost like it in a way it's
very realistic in that you know he's
midlife crisis rocking the leather
jacket and
rocking the hairstyle he thinks the kids
are are using he hold it on bro oh my
God but even his face is different like
yeah his face is different wider and I'm
like he just doesn't look like an
attractive dude
he's had he's had a rough go you know
seriously because I think Street Fighter
did that to Ken and now I'm taking his
daughter
yeah
he doesn't look right he looks like like
he turned down the like the lead role
and like what's what's the what's the
what's the um
it's like in days gone he's like I'm not
gonna take that day it's gone
Savvy tree yeah but I love I love Tekken
oh yeah me too oh yeah that's right
you've been playing recently right yeah
I just recently got back in it's been
years like I used to I used to check it
like two and three were like the the big
ones for me back in the day like and I
would play those endlessly with like
family like cousins and I would swamp it
was like it was like it was uh Nina
yoshimitsu and King
and yoshimitsu was just a complete jerk
yeah he was just like just the way they
usually like sit and spin and then
he had like the Harry Caray move yeah
if he turned around and kill you at the
same time and it was how did you play
him Chris did you play him would you
attack a lot or are you turtleing a lot
with him oh dude when I was younger I
had no idea what the hell I was just I
was just
mad I was mashing nonsense and just
trying to when I was younger I wasn't
really that good at fighting and I only
picked it up recently because I was at a
friend's house and we were like hey you
wanna my friend has an Xbox with every
single game he's ever ever remote like
half owned download through game it's
still on his hard drive because he just
doesn't like to get rid he Hoards I was
like how do you have all this how do you
have all this on your hard drive and
he's like yeah I got like a 10 terabyte
drive hooked up and I'm like why
so we're going through all these games
like it's like Kingdom for Keflings wow
I remember that I remember that just
weird nonsense and then I I see a like
Soul Calibur and like Tekken I was like
oh I got Tekken seven yeah I haven't
played Tekken in so long and so I jump
in and I'm like oh all my characters are
here
all right let me let me jump in with
Nina
he said Nina no that's console life he
didn't have to go update no patches
that's what I'm talking about
I recently downloaded a whole bunch of
patches for my Xbox series X
drivers
yeah no I'm sorry continue
[Laughter]
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the access gamer the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience and is the
leader of the fraud alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing today
you know I gotta um oh what happened I
gotta bring it back up again
another dear friend wow what the hell
all right so you know we have extended
family that's in California and those
are iron Lords as well so you have you
know Bone Thugs
[Music]
you know and
they have family as well yes so if
anybody has listened to any of my shows
if you listen to Kos you heard beats
yeah if you listen to in both characters
combat talk with the King
so
you know he did all that stuff and um
drum star produces if you look at him go
to him he's on my page the link is yeah
uh he passed away sadly on
on Friday in the morning
31 years old it's young uh he's young
Chris's brother Young Chris little Chris
yeah
group on uh and you know he's his family
that's family right there so um that
that kind of hit hard this weekend
and I just want to tell you to people
you know a lot of times us Grown Folk
and just younger dudes too if y'all
going to school and y'all really don't
have time most of the people that you
meet is usually online and the
connections that you make is real
connections online uh this guy was super
professional uh super uh talented very
very eager to uh to work and very eager
to take uh directions it's very rare to
find that uh when you come into the
artistic space so I just want to take my
hat off and I will truly miss them
because I got his last beat that he did
for me for Kos you know Kos is coming
back I'm just designing it or whatever
I'm getting a remix beat it's hard yeah
yeah he he did he did you know put the
question put the Crush in the chat for
the homie man throw that up and then
from put that up in there show some
respect real quick but yeah 31 years old
31 is younger 31 is Young
so what I've been playing this week uh
shout out to the new season in fortnite
oh my God Titan bro they keep doing it
they they did The Witcher 3
um last season pass now this season pass
is uh Attack on Titan yeah I took a
picture and send it to attic and I was
like call me now you know nerds playing
Destiny uh you know that's still fun
getting into that finishing up that
story
guilty gift oh touch I couldn't wait to
download this game I downloaded
immediately [__]
the fever starts and I don't know I
guess the fever must have hit uh solved
at the same time because this is channel
five at his finals before IOP that was
channel five yo we were playing Guilty
Gear shout out to Sinister we just
playing field tickets and all these
other games and this one kind of was
holding the torch for Street Fighter and
um the Neo Geo games when they were you
know taking a little Hiatus yeah just
keep going keep pushing I don't know
yeah I don't know yeah but these
animations are incredible I think this
they're at their Peak right now I played
Samurai Showdown this weekend I played
uh well this week uh Guilty Gear uh I
went over the JoJo Bizarre Adventures
remember that regular Street Fighter uh
went to Tekken I went to Mortal Kombat
fever just kicked in and I was telling
you frauds because I see you frauds
y'all keep coming for cogs like Cog be
outside [__] getting outside looking for
no smoke first of all you got to get
through the mini boss before
it's a technology
schools out there calling our [__] hey
God yeah see no and then I rebut him I
jump in and I said I'm outside
and you act like you didn't see what I
said oh they got that look yeah
outside with the guns trained let's do
this and you you like yeah but
bossy so I'm you know I was handing out
body bag and toe tags for those
individuals that wanted to jump up so
anytime you're ready I'm here and um
yeah can about kick about that action
oh I feel good what do you do now first
of his name little guilty gift okay he
made it happen yeah
station oh okay yeah
have them Game Pass
that's a good look it's it's crazy so
it's you know Trends are changing things
are actually changing you didn't know
what king was talking about you would
think that Phil made the game yeah like
Phil's designed the game you're gonna
act like you ain't gonna give him credit
give them all the smoke anytime
something go wrong now I feel you know
what you did feel but every time
something good go down now I feel
yeah yeah
holding that in Forever
anytime a football team loses we blame
the quarterback I don't care what the
quarterback did right anytime yeah I
don't blame anyone because I don't watch
football
you know the Bucks gotta stop somewhere
you know even if it's not even if it's
not necessarily Fair
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself this [__] don't be Laura Cognito
spread that really listen to Reverend
IOP not telling what you want to have
what you need to hear shout out to my
man Mr Maddie plays great to find the
Duke talking about what's going on with
us release dates and uh directs and you
know somebody got Spice it loud even
though see listen man you know it's a
very promotional very passionate subject
very passionate subject so shout out to
Heaven shout out to Dallas sub Community
for their crazy toxic public bathroom
stories it's absolutely out of control I
don't know what's going on over there
it's hilarious you know what I'm saying
shout out to them I need to regulate
that yeah they out of pocket they out of
pocket so a shout out to last word bonds
attack on Travis we have a man Paul
Tassie pulled up Paul Tassie pulled up
talking like for seeing what's going on
issues and such you know what I mean so
has been that and then uh yeah for me I
play in a little bit you know I didn't
really get a chance to get in there as
far as the day one raid contest mode
stuff so much going on but shout out to
everybody looks like they they finally
got it but man um that contest mode was
it's no joke I heard I heard I heard it
was controversy though oh yeah they
leaked the mechanics I heard the elite
who the boss was yeah dude like then
they had some other thing where
apparently there's some Pokemon
references and like
yeah like somebody was like I know it
has to be some Pokemon references
because somebody had like a Pokemon
thing and then they had like a bungee
thing and then bungee's like yo can I
copy your homework and was like I just
don't take so I was like what is going
on that's Pokemon related in a destiny
raid so now yeah I'm intrigued I I can't
even fathom that I haven't done the raid
yet I had a some friends of mine did it
so they could learn to learn the
mechanics and then we were gonna we're
gonna try and run it probably today but
I I didn't see any of that yeah that's
what I wanted I'm not I gotta defer the
addict on that I am not a Pokeball guy
so I don't know yeah I don't know what
the references are but I've been doing
that and then shout out to the rocket
blade Point got a good whole long
crossover event thing going on been
rocking that and they about to drop a
new character maybe one day the
community yeah and one day a community
should be with the laws I mean we gotta
figure it out we gotta figure it out
so that's been there you want to get
these super chats off before we get into
it yes sir so small Rules of Engagement
we don't have Chris the entire time so
I'll read these and then we'll we'll
read the rest afterwards up here but
hold on one second what we got what we
got we got nintend on the otaku remember
for one year ten dollar Super Chat shout
out to [__] for coming in second into
bitcast trivia show on season gaming
because he missed some Sega yeah yes the
rest of Sega related questions you
deserve that it was the Saturn who cares
about the Saturn
okay
I totally understand though it's a very
I technically have more answers right
than Colin he just won the two-point or
the ones for the extra points he has
some great errors yeah
he was fighting with the Judgment should
have been salute to the big cast salute
to whole glow it was for a great cause
you know what I'm saying face recovery
great to see all Ainsley trap oh man
that was I was so fun to be a part of
that so I'm a little tired today but it
was worth it being there before this
show there to salute them
we got Robert kellett two dollar Super
Chat violating staff delayed send sack 2
dropping November 20. I do not abide
these abbreviations let's stop this
right it's Maddie yeah Maddie with these
weird
abbreviations of games you know what I'm
saying like it started with hog leg and
now he's like yeah I'm mid so I said you
ain't calling my game mid bro like
man that's Luther Maddie and we got Sith
Lord remember for seven months Lord
bronze thank you sir thank you Lord for
making my special weekend even more
special with your show hope all is well
and you gentlemen have a great show and
a great week you as well
we got Nintendo Taco once again remember
for one year five dollar Super Chat
shout out to Chris Reagan for having the
best and most accurate pick of most
overrated game at the LSM event we can't
wait for it to go up for everyone
I mean you'll figure it out yeah yeah
for sure for sure
I'm excited to see how that turned out
like apparently it looks really like
I've seen some screenshots of it it
looks it looks crazy yeah I can't wait
that was fun bro that was a lot of fun
yeah it was no doubt what else we got
solved then we got like as king said
before Blaze 4K uh for the holy Place
Saloon five IOP memberships appreciate
that brother no doubt we have Robert
kellett once again five dollar Super
Chat so for this unofficial sacred X ILP
welcome to the realm Chris any tips for
Destiny 2 newbie you and [__] not lying
on witch Queen it's been great
oh man tips for a new I I you know
what's what I've not I haven't been a
destiny newbie for about a decade feels
like so I I have no idea I had a friend
of mine
he was like Hey I'm thinking of getting
into it where should I start and I I had
no idea what to tell them yeah actually
I was like I I mean start the biggest I
I said that to me I told him don't yeah
that's the biggest tip
yeah just stay out of there
it's really cool but I I totally listen
it's a YouTube channel go go to my
neighbor's wife and figure it out
I say not to most people who are into it
but uh no I mean um my tip honestly
would be find like find people to play
it with because because a squad is going
to help you run through and it's and
it's also just a lot more fun yeah when
you get when you get a team of six full
people and like a really complicated
mechanically driven like encounter it is
so funny I don't know so it's funny how
angry people get yes it is funny oh the
friendships is on test right then okay
continue oh no no 100 like I I only run
raids with the people I've known for
like a decade
anybody else I would be like you know no
you're not cutting it sorry get out of
here
I also gotta know your voice just based
like
in an instant I can't I can't have some
random like a couple maybe it's four of
us and then there's two extra random
people and then I have to be like
um uh Metal Gear David
you uh can you jump on the plate with
the Scion spawns in the right place and
he goes like I'm no I'm Daniel and it's
like oh my God no no I can't do that
random okay
I'm Daniel I love sacred symbols Chris
it's your mouth
you already know what else we got some
we got a Dragonheart Yobe member for 20
months shout out to you brother no doubt
Peace Love Like The Streak continues
with the undefeated IOP safe to say
Sundays belong to y'all continue the
great work always IOP ain't a word it's
a brain
okay your new favorite podcast okay oh
we taking the girl we snatching okay
ain't coming in June
[Music]
I'm not really into the Dragon Ball
Fighters except for the ark system uh
dude I know the tenkachi means a lot to
you Chris yeah
in general was like it was my exactly
because I was I was I think in like
Middle School when that was out so that
was like a prime time that was my
introduction to Dragon Ball Z in general
I didn't know I didn't really watch the
show or know really anything about it
until I played the first so that's uh
that's like a really special game to be
and the fact that they're making a
fourth one after what feels like 20 20
years is insane and I know I'm I'm part
of the problem here because if it's the
if it is the same exact game it was on
the PlayStation 2 with like three new
characters I would be like yo give me
the collector's edition
I did play those games
they were fun it's ridiculous because
you can play as like chaotsu that's that
tiny clown and then you can fight you
play the um you can fight a two-scale
great ape Vegeta or whatever and it just
looks ridiculous and it was it was not
competitive at all really you could you
could take it seriously but it was more
about just how ridiculous that game was
and I'm stoked to see you could play
with the the uh the mini cells I can't
remember yeah every single cell you
could play it you could place like
random like like just freeze a soldier
number two it's like just the roster was
insane this is so cool they had like a
lot of them had like
they would do them like what if kind of
things or yeah what if this boss won in
this show like show like a history that
would like a phrase a little one yeah
and you could do
you could do Fusion dances wrong and you
could have like these fat or like
emaciated versions of characters it was
I had a I I was nasty with kid booing
those games kid movies
that's so crazy out y'all talking
another language
this is the first time I felt like I was
like I don't know what they talking
about
now you and song know how I feel when
you talk about the atariable Dragon Ball
the imported Dragon Ball Z fighters from
the SNES days you guys didn't play it
doesn't play uh Fighters Dragon Ball Z
Fighters
that's a beautiful thing that's a
beautiful game man yeah me me and solve
is fighting junkies so we played
anything that we played it was
competitive bro we had every weird
fighting game
oh karate chips
right did you guys ever uh did you guys
ever mess with uh bloody roar oh yes
sorry about that one yes
to this day I think that is probably the
most underrated fighter there absolutely
yo that was the reason to turn on your
PlayStation
that was there that they're playing uh
Mortal Kombat they're playing Street
Fighter but he was like this bloody war
though
isn't Bloody War the ones where you like
transform into the animals you could
transform into like these uh like these
uh these and but there were these ridic
there was one uh stun the insect it was
like my baby
it was like this mummy that he could
turn into this giant like Beetle
mosquito and it was disgusting it was
his voice was gross everything about it
was gross and then you would you would
like charge with your head and people
would go bursting through the ring
that famous like replay it free time
like
awesome shout out to them
I did play as far as fight as I did play
the Naruto Storm games
though why do you act like I didn't win
time on fighting battles
I threw the fight like Cog through the
fight when he was uh with Colin today
y'all messy don't do that don't do that
stuff that you knew I didn't mess with
the sadder like that so you knew I would
they had Saturday questions it was over
oh man yeah cognition received a little
PayPal bonus
yeah sorry for your lost King all I can
do is try to cheer you up with this
[Music]
salute here we have DJ auro a member for
two years like five dollar Super Chat
long time listen to first time caller
wanted to pop in and say keep up the
amazing work yin's are the best has to
hey bestie you guys are ridiculous he's
ridiculous
I said there's a king online and I'll
say it again young Icarus Bethesda flew
too close to the Sun September 6 are you
kidding me I'm done oh no star field as
12 months passed by but Todd Howard's
still Pretty Fly for a White Guy yo yeah
salute salute
then we have Astro parrot King oh the
homie Rizzy ray gun in the realm I like
that hello
octopath two question marks all right I
joined fire we reviewed it all asking
you Chris oh yeah uh for octopath yeah
oh man I don't know dude that's a
negative that's that's like look that's
a common experience for sure I'm so bad
at uh I don't know RPGs like that are
really
I feel like I have no time to really
suck into them same and I love I love
the art the visual style of that game a
lot but I I I'm so bad at getting into
those
yeah I really like the first one it was
a pretty decent experience it would have
been great if it was on a game pass the
second one right I wouldn't I would I
would have appreciated just the game
being on him go check it you did that
for us though who did that you know who
did that to us Sony
I would say it's mainly Square Enix go
check out that review up on Lords of
gaming.net right now and we have a
Rory Hale 25 Super Chat shout out to the
Lords and chat all these games my
backlog body count is ridiculous yes it
is yeah
unless we got so yeah it's crazy gaming
14 remember for 38 months Lord bronze
shout out to the fire team members that
couldn't make the raid the experience
wasn't the same without Coggin addict we
will be back it's all good now baby
everything's good he didn't even
mentioned me yeah you not you got a part
you know yeah
[Music]
whatever sir let's get these Matt
without fear remember for 14 months Lord
silver tin foil had time Sony have been
saying Microsoft could add bugs to Cod
didn't they help fund the Callisto
protocol which yeah noticeably worse on
the Xbox
conspiracy theories the thing Microsoft
could do this y'all guys did that y'all
messy moving on
so you're sticking around Chris to see
Cog take King's knees
he don't know the context that sounds
crazy
no you know it's funny man
could have took your knees easily again
King that would be the third pair of
knees I'd have got for you
transcode addict be quiet
instead you know I I kind of got the
same I'll tell you that you know yeah
oh yeah you got that residue before
jacket right up you got that right now
for sure
you got London train station wow
interest you in a watch
Yo you out of pocket
I'm just sitting at the train station
can I interest you in King's knees
we'll see what happens with these bats
returned we'll see how it goes
what you selling what you got
he's at a low price sound like you got a
pocket full of coins because I got so
many of them
arcade with the coins in his pocket
that's dirty that's dirty I'm not I'm
not co-signing that behavior saw please
please danger you XO ten dollars in the
chat gents I've been a Star Citizen
Banker since 2016. oh man oh Jesus a few
months the Starfield there's nothing oh
my goodness you still waiting ninja bro
we have the zip Davis once again five
dollars for chat all joking aside I just
wanted to send some Pax cash good luck
oh you do love you guys are the best
welcome Mr gun to the round no down Mr
gun bang bang
uh beam struggles ruin so many
controllers beam struggles oh yeah so
that's a dragon best dragon ball game
when when the beat when the like beams
would Clash
do the sticks you have to rotate the
sticks like like faster than this
yeah so you had to like so you had to
like basically like rotate the the
sticks like it's both of them as fast oh
that's crazy
he's talking about on the PlayStation
yeah it was easier on the PS2 because a
little wonky but yeah you know what's
what's funny is um I just play Resident
Evil 5 with uh with grace and the very
end where your chevo tried to get up on
that little lava Mountain Point like
that's the hardest like push-up button
sequence I've ever done in games like
she and and I can't usually I I be
shoving because I can do that but every
time I have to be Chris I'm like okay
before the match I was like okay babe
look you're gonna fall in that lava like
30 times okay like don't be discouraged
it took her like 30 minutes to get past
that and then I died and she had to do
it again
wow that's crazy what else we got so we
gotta fly through and we have yeah baby
five dollar Super Chat either so squat
Dominican Republic or the unsettled
systems of Starfield September 6 I'm
exploring Untamed lands and tearing up
the natives
oh yeah
fantastic I mean to be fair I didn't
realize what that was yeah I knew what
that was I didn't realize it was a place
in the Dominicans
wow wow very questionable God bless to
you sir continue yourself
that we have a wolf of Darkness with the
37 new Arab every
Emrick what's up iron Lords myself and
my friends would like to know Lord King
David's opinion on the latest Michael
pactor interview with Destin peace from
Dubai this podcast is fire absolutely
okay I gotta check it out I didn't check
it out it's good
yeah it's good I caught it yesterday
wow wow
your mess is back your business okay
Chris this is what I'm subjected to you
too on a weekly basis let's play with
each other's joysticks five dollars
can't wait to play Dragon Balls booty
guy
oh man that's on a private patreon wow
that's an exclusive tier
it's it's it's uh it's Galo all over
again
hey stop can I please get the following
in a husky ad read voice
touch jealousy Obsession forever
desperation by Jim Ryan
give me messy and guest welcome Chris
hit the like let's save some Indonesian
yeah what's the rare edible cake what's
the rare animal we say when they hit the
like today oh they have the Indonesian
koala
but every life
chlamydia
something actually I think actually for
real is that I feel like like koalas
actually like had like 90 of them have
like chlamydia or something oh
yes
something ever happened to uh the
narrator of Halo man
yes and we got the voice reads man we
hiring they Chuck him and Chuck bodak
you have no idea the atrocities that
these guys have committed bro you just
to ask did you guys see the the reviews
like the Xbox reviews for a while long
it's like a bunch of people rage
quitting the first boss
it's crazy I saw if you guys want to see
a video on it because we obviously we
can't talk about it like to a good
degree like go look at kids Smooth video
like he literally went over it's so many
people saying it was fun but I couldn't
beat that first boss
that first boss that first bus
apparently the hardest thing in the game
no it's not all right well I mean well
logically it has to be right because you
know the game less than you would than
you would right further right that's
kind of like the default situation with
all those games where it's like okay the
first one's always gonna be harder
because you're just getting used to it
and you're just you're a newbie with
like fresh legs but like uh
I I've heard from a couple people it's
like it's one of the harder encounters
yeah and then after the harder encounter
it's like it's a lot not a lot easier
but definitely like a lot more
manageable I still haven't I still
haven't messed around with it yet but uh
I haven't downloaded I gotta I gotta
maybe I'll mess with it today I saw I
saw a kid smoo posted on Twitter ask
because he said I will pay someone to
beat the second Lube yeah it's real out
here so we gotta get these up this last
one I think we good we got Kelly 17 two
pound Super Chat addict out here with
the detective trench coat if you if you
say it's a detective crunch coat that's
fine I wanted it's something else for me
try to stay warm man it's against the
law I guess
Robert killer two dollars
JLo is joysticks Game of the Year wow
all right
do you think playing
salute salute we good we got Kelly you
all good all right
all right but it was
I'll get through everything all right so
now that we got finished with uh the
super chats and what the Lords have been
playing we gotta focus on Lord Chris
Reagan his video game system history his
journey into content creation and comedy
and of course Wetland up to the stock
tank and that sacred symbols PlayStation
podcast so Lord Crystal start from the
very beginning what were some of the
first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
oh my God probably I had I started with
the NES which is kind of bizarre because
I feel like
yeah I I was born in 93 so like
obviously like most most people had
PlayStations and stuff but I think I
started with uh you know duck content
and that kind of thing I got introduced
to like the the natural progression of
consoles like just added like a quicker
Pace like I had NES and then like a year
later it was like PlayStation or
whatever oh okay okay and then after
that it was you know PS2 Xbox all that
stuff but
um
no I had I there is an inexplicably
there's a box in my family's house full
of Genesis games no Genesis I have no
memories of playing Genesis I've never
played any of these games I don't know
who I don't know where this box came
this is a random box of Genesis games I
think I think it's
cousin who my family dares not speak of
or something
because no one's explained it to me at
all and it's just it's you know
suspicious I got I got I got a theory
and this is the cousin that nobody knows
arguing over which one was better you
got rid of them
secretly what happened is Chris raygon
got a lost one brother he don't know
that was from the family
legitimate Child come on don't do that
somebody sent me somebody sent me a
picture like a long time ago on Twitter
it was like is it a picture on Twitter
and it said are you in Germany right now
and it was just a picture of some guy in
like a German airport and it looked it I
I thought it was me
it messed me up I was like what is going
on
I wish I could find that too this is
like 2016 2017. wow that's the guy yeah
yeah he's probably a psycho Genesis whoa
like a lot of uh Platformers Tekken was
like a big early early one and then I
found uh Halo later on at a friend's
house and it kind of blew my mind I
didn't understand
how someone could go from like playing
GoldenEye to playing uh like Crimson
Skies you know what I mean like in the
same game like he got he was like flying
a Banshee around I was like oh cool Jet
game then he got out and started
shooting aliens I was like this is I
don't understand now let me actually
yeah because there's so much stuff going
on my question like did you guys do the
system link thing with the TVs or we
just kind of just playing the campaign
it was it was just normal split screen
like all of this stuff I was completely
out of my depth with I was only like
kind of into video games I played them
at friends houses but I didn't really
understand the I still I didn't
understand like what they were really
like I understood how movies were made I
understood that how from a young age
that like oh people edit and like
they're actors that go film but like
video games for whatever reason I was
like this is like a portal into some
other dimensions I really had no it was
like magic to me and then I think 2005
2006 with the when I got the 360 and it
we had like online for the first time
and I was I was playing splits or couch
Co-op or like competitive multiplayer
with like people in Egypt in London and
I was like these are real people that
broke me again yes it was like just all
this stuff was like I can't yeah that's
real that's real I mean especially I'm
sorry continue no no no it's it's a
crazy I mean we take it for granted now
because it's in everything it's in your
it's in your Subway Surfer games that
you uh you you play underneath Tick Tock
videos but you know you know it used to
be like a it was like a new thing at one
point where it's like I didn't
understand it yeah uh and then Halo 3
obviously was like a big thing it's like
with Machinima and that got me into
making videos trust me I was I was doing
videos on YouTube from probably like
2006 I started in 2006. okay okay uh I
want you to back up one second before we
get we want to get into the content
creation but I did want to ask you like
you were talking about like I said the
the realization obviously that you know
as a young kid you're figuring out
what's going on you're getting that
control of what's going on but the key
part that you mentioned that I want to
focus on is like Xbox Live and the
ability to communicate with other people
that are real people in another area
like did you start establishing those
friendships in in the 360 eras kind of
when you start to be more social gamer
through to the introduction of Xbox Live
100 yeah like that I I I met I met a
friend in in London it was like one of
the first people I bet he he would he
caught he was like the first comment on
my videos when I was when I was posting
them it was like Hey you play Halo
coolest play I still I just met him for
the first time a few months ago in
person well see this is uh you know it
goes back a long time so like it's it
was like a whole new
I don't know it was it was it was a
whole new world for me especially as a
kid and you know when you grow up in you
know when you're a kid in in the mid
2000s there's a lot of
there's a lot of like hey don't go
outside yeah
don't you know don't you know there's
crazy if you kill people yes yeah stay
home 9 11's happen sometimes stay home
to do um do so calm with the PlayStation
no PlayStation online because my
earliest online is like uh you know
probably Genesis no x-band oh really
yeah no I I feel like I was probably too
young at that time to really grasp any
of that like and having to set up like a
the thing with the Xbox was that it was
just kind of in the box right and I knew
that it had existed with the the
original Xbox I understood that but I
never I never messed with it I was you
know my that was too young my parents
were like yo we don't want you playing
with random people what's that exactly
uh and I didn't even know that Sega had
any kind of like capabilities
that that goes way back but um of course
it goes way back I don't know the
Voiceover IP came with PlayStation
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah he was able to
play and usually everybody played at
night because if somebody picked up the
phone and broke the connection
11 o'clock at night when everybody sleep
and you got your little headpiece in and
you know you're quiet and you're playing
but you hear somebody random yells out
die yeah oh yeah
World men were made in them Call of Duty
lobbies though real man was made okay
yeah man that 360 area was like a big a
big deal for me most of the friends that
I have still to this day in person or
online are the people that I met uh
running horde mode in Gears two or like
running through Halo Halo 3 lobbies or
you know the same people I I run Destiny
with today
so you know it's absolutely like a huge
formative and also just a formative
thing for for career stuff too because
like when I found out you could make
movies with that um with that theater
mode I was already edited I was already
editing stuff when I was like seven damn
on Windows Movie Maker and stuff and
just like trying to figure figure that
stuff out so but I was like oh you could
I remember specifically thinking like oh
people are making movies in Halo and
it's like oh I have like access to like
these big sci-fi sets these like these
like actual explosions these like car
chase I could like and it was like so
much fun like making stuff those are all
gone now by the way you cannot see those
horrible videos
like 12 making them but uh but it was
cool it got me started and I I you know
I I evolved over time just doing
different stuff yeah so I was doing
YouTube he was doing YouTube for like
seven years before I got any money out
out of it but um so I was gonna ask you
so pretty much just it was just a
natural progression for you to just at
that young and say hey I just want to do
content I want to make a channel like it
was just there was no individual
inspiration to say hey this person looks
cool I want to do something like that
what kind of drove you
Cinema in general yeah that was that was
real was kind of interesting to me but I
I didn't uh it was before YouTube was
YouTube you know what I mean it was it
was when YouTube was new so there wasn't
like I want to be PewDiePie
it was more like wow people are making
money making their own stuff that was
what was appealing to me and I knew
immediately like in in when I started
High School it was like oh there's you
know YouTube's crazy and there's going
to be money in this and I want to focus
on this it's like it's interesting it's
new it's going to be like very very
different and uh you know that's a very
hard sell
uh it's a very hard sell your parents
yes I was about to ask you the parents
let you rock they love like they let you
rock my parents were In fairness they
were super supportive like they were
really cool about it but they were but
they were also like you know like hey
you gotta you know you should probably
go to school because they grew up they
grew up in a time when College actually
gave you something as opposed to as
opposed to the hustle Rippling debt and
uh inability to afford housing so uh so
I you know I went to I went to Community
College for a little bit I went to um
you know film school I wanted to go to
game design school in uh in Washington
uh to Japan I think it was where they
made uh where they picked up the guys
who made portal oh okay that whole
digipen remember that yeah
you take it back you're right yeah the
guys who made uh I think was called
narbacular drop at that time and they
picked up like a squad of people from
Netflix and made made a portal and I was
like that's the school I want to be at
and then they're like that's expensive
and I was like fair
fair enough uh so you know I just messed
around I did
film school which is you know not smart
don't do it don't do it a tremendous
waste uh and uh luckily the channel
started
picking up at some point like 2014 2015.
let me ask you what was the moment for
you Channel wise where you like if it's
a singular moment that you could think
of and say okay I got something people
like tuning in to me and my content
there was it was like it was a pretty
um
it was pretty gradual increase it was it
was very Biz I think once I started
making stuff regularly like once I was
like okay I'm gonna I'm gonna post
several times a week that's when it just
started exploding because people were
like oh this is happening regularly but
like I didn't really have like a solid
idea I just knew I wanted to make stuff
I would make I would make music I would
do you know I would do comedy I would do
I would cover like current events I
would do like new I did my one of my
most popular videos back in the day was
like taking the piss out of Fox News I
don't know if you guys remember
um if you guys remember the Mass Effect
uh Fox News Scandal wait I don't even
know about it
it was it was it was like Fox News from
like 2008 and they were like is uh Mass
Effect a game with graphic sex
and uh Jeff Keeley came on oh I gotta
look at this up I never knew about this
it is a clad I made I made videos about
that stuff and and just ranting about it
basically like how stupid is this [__]
uh sorry
you're good but like uh yeah how dumb is
this and and you know I and I think I
realized at that point it's like oh
people like hearing
me talk about you know current event
especially like if it's it's games
related or pop culture related and so I
had that in the back of my mind but it
would be a while before I settled into
that got you gotcha okay like what's
what's the landscape as far as you know
uh internet pop culture or like uh you
know internet politics like what's
what's the vibe here and uh and I would
I would start doing that stuff no good
video game stuff every now and again too
but yeah and I I do want to um
transition because you talk about pop
culture obviously the video games is
core but your commit your comedy bro you
funny as hell so it's like you gotta
talk about that like how did that your
comedic Journey kind of start because
yeah I mean I started doing Santa
recently uh like actually well not it
feels recently because the pandemic was
a Time Warp but I uh I started I've
always wanted to do stand up I was
respected like you know George Carlin
and and these Dave Chappelle and like
these amazing gadgets
um Comedians and I was like wow it must
be amazing to do that it must be amazing
to just like have a job where your
entire goal is to just get on stage and
make a ton of people laugh and then
leave
sounds awesome and just be able to
afford like that sounds amazing uh and I
remember just like really studying it
for a long time but I was I was too
nervous to do it I don't know what it is
or something and I gotta be real like
I've done it three times and I started
the week before the pandemic happened so
like all my momentum was immediately
killed it's like there are no clubs
possible time to start yeah but
it was uh it's still scary like it's way
scarier than boxing
[Laughter]
it is the solar plexus a million times
that's fine it hurts punch me in the
face knock me in the jaw clocked me out
knocked me out for a little bit that's
fine I'm not nearly as scared as I was
when I like went on stage for in front
of a bunch of strangers and they had the
expectation that I was gonna crack them
up
something funny funny man yo for real
it's it's it is it is
scary yeah it is a scary like and it
never got less scary but like the three
times I did it I was like it was scary
every single time uh but you know I I
did I did three times one show was the
first show I got lucky it was like
really really good it was a good crowd
it was like it was a Friday night people
are enjoying themselves
I also got a good laugh because I'm a
short guy I'm like five foot four so
like
the mic for the previous comedian was
like super high oh yeah yeah yeah
I kind of played it for like a joke I
was like pretending to struggle with it
a little bit I think I got the audience
on my side a little bit nice second the
second time was horrible oh what
happened I think I got like maybe like
two laughs in five minutes rough it was
I wanted to die that silence though that
uncomfortable silence broke and it's
they tell you too it's like they tell
you they told me before they got on it's
like listen it's a Tuesday
so and I was like what does that mean
and then
five minutes later I knew exactly what
that meant you are not at comedy clubs
on Tuesdays if they're having if they're
ready to laugh yeah
he's a miserable drug [__] why do
Tuesday dudes gotta be busy yeah so then
I was like all right I'll I'll come
Friday again and then that was that was
also that was a better show it wasn't as
good as the first one because like again
I think I I got just like a really lucky
crab it was it was still a good one I
was like wow I think I could you know I
could flush this out I could do this and
then uh 2020 happened and ruined ever
yeah yeah I still haven't I still
haven't gotten gotten back to doing it I
want to do it but uh I've also just you
know I've been training for this fight
so we're gonna get into it like had like
no time but yeah no it's it's
I don't know my Journey's been so
schizophrenic I feel like yeah it's it's
it's very easy it's all over there it's
all over the place I was looking at it
I'm like yeah okay yeah your journey is
supposed to be like like a spider web
all over the place yeah yeah girl what
sticks hey you saw that that's what you
did I had a friend of mine I had like my
I had my first girlfriend in high school
just reached out to me she's like you're
boxing like out of nowhere it's like
that's how she reached out to me after
like 15 years let's get right to it
let's get right to it I got a question
for you right sure absolutely because
it's it's a box is high I know you get
it when you when you're in the zone 100
when you start hitting the bag right now
it's a build up to uh establishing
stamina
and then when you break through I know
the first time you was hitting the bag
that that first uh three minutes hitting
that bag is like what the hell when is
the Bell gonna ring did you get to that
point now where you just hit the bag and
you're not even sweating it's like four
or five rounds and now you're starting
to build up that sweat and before you
know you're just flowing around the back
what what is your style what is what
what would you say Chris Reagan's style
is when he's preparing because how you
prepare is how you fight so what is your
style well I don't want to give too much
away in case
stop listening yeah in case there's some
in case there's some opposition research
there there are there yeah I do it yeah
it makes sense people people do it it
makes sense but uh you know I I would
say that
I still I I have that feeling where it's
like when is this bill gonna go off but
I I don't it's not at the Forefront of
my mind like I know I'm feeling it but I
just you know I'm just gonna keep
pushing and then like and the bell rings
and then I Collapse the
but dude I have never sweat like this in
my life yes doing this like I I couldn't
when I was before I started this I was
like I just don't sweat and then and
then I realized that like oh no I just
don't do things
it's what it is so you know it's it's
you know the prep is ridiculous my coach
has to be like pushing cars up up hills
and yeah and just ridiculous stuff I'm
like running about like five miles
um and and it's you know it's it's crazy
it's all to build stamina because salmon
is like honestly like the most important
the people who are gas if you're gassed
then you're screwed right basically yeah
you do wall sets
wall sets uh yeah yeah we do all sets
yeah we do um I'm talking about guys
this box and stuff all right so the
reason why I'm asking him these things
is because I want to know if his core is
centered I want to know does he work on
footwork opposed to hands you know this
is the questions on the mask that create
a class talk I'm I'm definitely uh I'm
really good with my footwork I think
because I think I benefit based a lot
because I used to play baseball and my
coach was my coach was like oh so you
got you got a good idea but and I I
would run uh you know every now and
again just to make sure that I wasn't my
legs weren't atrophy because this like
doing this job is so sanitary in
comparison oh yeah so like most things
you do so like I try to I try to do as
much as I can uh within you know reason
but like when I started this it was
crazy baseball in infield or outfield
uh I was
actually man this was ages ago I think I
was I think I was Outfield so I was I
was doing a lot of running I was like I
was like trying I was catching the
people who were like you know
um but uh I was a good hitter though
like I I don't know why I stopped you
know what it is I felt like I was
expected to because I'm I'm Puerto Rican
and my dad was like you gotta play
baseball that sounds familiar to
yourself yeah that sounds very familiar
that sounds funny
right out of the room with the baseball
dude my dad my dad was like oh you're oh
you can walk now here's a Yankee cat
you know what's funny
yeah absolutely a lot of people don't
know about I played baseball for like
four years old
what were you like what position
um I can't remember
shortstop that's what I like about right
on Friday Night Fights Friday football
he was doing short stuff but the the
footwork the footwork for the for the
baseball is really especially I'll feel
the info doesn't matter because the
thing about baseball shortstop
I played third and the ball comes at you
fast with no the only thing about it you
don't it's a tighter space right but um
yeah man the footwork when I started
when I started doing like boxing with
you came when I started doing like just
training MMA and training more even
though I never thought but I did a
trained MMA the footwork all of that
stuff and the stuff that I did when I
wrestled as well all of that came into
play and it was just like wow okay I
have this skill already it's just a
matter of tuning yeah
I was like maybe 12 like it was it was I
was really really young when I was doing
that it was mainly one of those things
where my mom was working two jobs and
she low-key needed a babies
I think that's kind of what it was for
me too like it was just that there's I
don't know what it is with Hispanic I
don't know what it is specifically East
Coast yes East Coast like Dominican
Caribbean like that that kind of like
areas like play baseball you have to try
in case you're a run yeah right just in
case you never know right
what's crazy about Saul he's a Mets fan
but he's a block or two away from you no
he a Yankee man I'm not no I'm a Yankee
fan so this is my story my dad my dad
projected the Mets on to me because I
when I as I'm growing up right and as
you're growing up and you you have more
of a sense of your surroundings I'm like
Dad we live like blocks away from Yankee
Stadium why aren't we Yankee fans we got
into this whole thing all the Yankees
were racists back in 1920 and I'm like
they're all the teams are racist back in
1920 like
or not
still playing but the idea that they
would still like like these people like
Derek Jeter is actually 89 and he's
still playing
that was it and so again you go with
what your parents go to and then when I
was able to when I was able to sort of
think for myself I was like no you know
what I'm gonna go with the guys that are
down the block and they suck back then
yeah it was hard to train because again
I was a big message
that's right that's how I remember you
when I went to school with you that's
how I remember you I was I think I was a
Yankee fan just by pure osmosis like I
didn't because I didn't really you know
I I was good at baseball relatively but
like I you know I didn't I I wasn't like
super into like I didn't sit and watch
games or anything uh I was a Yankee fan
purely because like I like that logo and
they're close yeah yeah it's close
enough yeah yeah it's like it's like
standard home teams it's like whenever
whenever it's like whenever the Giants
are in the Super Bowl it's like well I
guess I'll watch it because I don't know
I don't watch football at all but like
I'll watch this because I know what the
Giants are
um
no no doubt oh no we got uh how many in
here boy you hit that like
yeah
this man is respected everybody gun in
the building Indonesian red nose koalas
you know if he's absolutely on that so
you get ready for Korean Clash super
dope I wanted to get back to um content
creation for a second because I want to
talk about the homies I'm saying Tom
sweetie some black guy that's his name
literally literally I always have to
clarify it's like oh yeah you do a
podcast like yeah my roommate Sweeney
and uh some black guy
what and everybody's like what do you
what and I was like I swear to you
that's just that's his name I swear I
think he did it on purpose I think he
did it on purpose that's literally the
only reason he did it like I I just so
he has to have that awkward
clarification conversation whenever
somebody else brings him up I love it
let's get it stock take let's talk about
the origin story man how the whole thing
stopped oh man so Derek well Sweeney and
I like we've known each other for a very
long time we went to college together uh
I hated him uh for a long time yeah he
was just just immediately we would argue
all the time and it was funny like like
our friends would laugh at like whenever
we would like get into arguments and
just like all right well I didn't think
anything of it but then we we moved to
Los Angeles kind of around the same time
and I was and I remember thinking like
God damn it he followed me
and and so and he roomed with us uh me
and me and my my friend Jalen who we we
drove we did the drive from New York to
California about we did it in about
three days because we had like no money
I respect it yeah it was rough that was
that was a rough one oh God I don't even
want to think about that I never want to
do that cross-country road again oh that
sounds brutal never again it was so bad
we're like cramped in like some like
1996 Ford Taurus
what's funny is uh my half my family's
here and have my family's in Arizona so
my grandfather especially he he could
make that trip in like two days that's
wild man salute to anybody doing that no
man but uh yeah so so we we live
together uh for a little bit he needed a
place to stay so he crashed in our
living room uh
but I just did not lie I used to be so
upset that he was like he was inside I
was I was like starting this new chapter
of my life and here's this guy who just
argues with me all the time it's just
like in my living room constantly I was
like all right you know what I'm I'm
making videos I'm get you're you have to
pay me back for this somehow so like I'm
gonna use I'm gonna use your your
torment for for
Content because people liked it people
had fun and then you know we I met Derek
sometime some time later he was also
doing YouTube stuff kind of similar
stuff to what I was doing and we all
kind of linked up uh and did these
collaboration videos once a year where
we would all like we would read like
dumb nonsense on Twitter and we would
make fun of it and people people loved
it uh
and we were like this is just three of
us just riffing like we did this all the
time why not just why not just you know
why not make something out of it and it
took us a while to do that because I I
was so averse to podcasts specifically
doing them because I was like I don't
want a schedule
I don't want to be I don't want to be
tied though I don't wanna I I don't want
to have to wake up at any point ever
like I want to be able to wake up and
start my day like I'm I'm My Own I'm My
Own director here right and so the
thought of like all right guys let's
meet every Sunday or like let's meet
every like Wednesday at like nine is
that good for you like no okay it's just
so over so I you know it took a while to
really convince me to do it but I was
like you know what yeah maybe there's
something here so we got something
together and you know it worked out the
show is a mess
I'm astounded that that people know the
changes y'all going though is wow funny
though I ain't gonna front like it'd
just be random and y'all get so
passionate about it and it's it's
natural chemistry so I I can see it we
had a recent one where I think it was
Derek and Sweeney were arguing about
like who was the better uh I think it
was Ray Charles versus Steve yeah Stevie
Wonder I saw what I drew y'all was wow
it's Jamie Foxx and Mike Tyson and Jamie
Foxx tells the story that Stevie ain't
really blind he said Mike started while
and now and Stevie got up was like
excuse me
that's Wow Mike Tyson stop swinging on
people
so yeah yeah I'm gonna go with Ray
Charles on that one yeah
salute to the stock man that judge wow
funny love the chemistry there seeing
y'all moving and shaking then I also
want to ask you obviously but a lot of
people also know you for is that sacred
symbols number one PlayStation podcast
Last Stand media fam in the building so
like let's talk about the origin story
there how did that whole thing develop
it I feel like I should remember more of
this than I did because like I swear
because there's a I feel like there was
a point where Colin just was in my life
and I don't remember him I don't
remember the point where he just showed
up like he followed me on Twitter and I
remember being like Oh that guy I know
that guy and then he was I think he said
like come on my I think he said come on
fireside chats or something this is like
an interview show he did a long time ago
and I was like yeah yeah all right and I
did it and I think a year went by and
then you know he was doing something he
like he had stepped away from from video
games he was doing like history or like
or something something else and then a
year went by and he was looking to start
uh a video games podcast generally he
was like I was like I think I want to
get back into video games and I you know
he was he pitched two ideas to me uh he
I don't know why he came to it was so
weird like he said I don't know why no
no because because like I because he was
like because I just tweet about Halo all
the time like that was my thing like I
was tweeting about Halo all the time I
was like I was like frustrated like what
the hell's going on with this thing
um and he was like I
I think he messaged me he said like you
you you seem like you understand a lot
about the industry despite the fact that
you don't really make content around it
I think that's interesting uh and I want
to have like a different flavor going
into like whatever whatever it is we're
doing and the first pitch was a general
video game show just not not PlayStation
at all oh not even PlayStation Centric
okay I don't know and then the second
one or the the audio order of these
might be reversed but and the second one
was a PlayStation show because that's
like the what he was doing before
um and it was basically up to me what I
wanted to do and I was like well I'm I'm
an Xbox guy primarily like that's just
kind of where I've been for a while it's
like you know it's just where I've been
I don't know it's just like just where I
was and I thought about it but I was
like I feel like if we just did a
general one
it would just be another one right it
would just be another General one and I
feel like if we if we focus on
Playstation we can at least that that's
like a smaller
that's a smaller you know group of
podcasts for sure like and so I figured
like if we came out swinging in that
field we could really
it would be a lot bigger and I think it
would be a lot more important
and so you know we we just we met up at
this place in Santa Monica I think it
was like a
this is some bistro place shout out to
that Bistro shout out to that Bistro I
wish I could remember exactly where it
was I think it was around Joe's Pizza in
on Santa Monica Pier but
and we we just decided like yeah we'll
do this and uh we started it and it's
been five years and I can't believe it I
know and it'll get original construction
just you and Kyle this is pre-production
yeah this is free Dustin it was just it
was just me and Colin the show was like
only two hours now it's 15. yeah okay
we want more they like we love the five
six hours yeah yeah yeah I have a I have
a catheter installed
you know just for posterity the absolute
salute the sacred sleep all that man
yeah you killed it brother absolutely
killed it I want to say um magic moments
because to me I feel like you got so
many different things as far as content
creation comedy doing the boxes thing
you got all the podcasts you got all the
stuff going on I was gonna say just as a
Creator in general like what do you
consider your magic moment when you kind
of take a step back you're like yo this
is cool
like a Magic Moment yeah like any
singular moment in content creation of
what you've been up until this point
where you sat back and you go wow this
is really cool
I think I mean this this this Probably
sounds a little lame but I think the the
second I realized that I could
that I could live on my own doing doing
like just stuff I was doing anyway like
oh I'm doing you know I'm doing videos
and I was doing videos for like seven
straight years you know to no real
um success I just liked doing it it was
it was fun for me it was like it was
like it was a way for me to hone editing
and it was like it was just fun uh and I
remember as it was getting more and more
profitable and I could like actually
like oh I can I can I can move now out
of my out of my parents place this is
crazy my parents were like this is
my parents were my parents are really
supportive they are like but they were
also concerned and they were like listen
is this a real job dude
I was like and so I was like let me show
you and then I bought them like the
nicest TV they'd ever seen and then they
were and then my dad was like
my dad my dad was like yes
okay keep doing that keep doing that
what's going on yeah
he was like yeah yeah keep keep doing
that thing
did they find out a year later Chris
just backed out a crack
Peabody scams
YouTube
it's it's weird it's not even
necessarily a moment in in content
creation it's not like any one video
that I made it like I I'm I'm pretty
happy with like everything I've made
generally like and it's it's cool like
just the people I've worked with is cool
but I think
honestly what it was that it was that
moment when I was able to like really
convince my parents that it was like it
was it was actually happening like
that's a real thing because it's hard to
I don't know it's a weird it's a weird
thing to convey to people of a certain
generation that this is you know even to
me it's kind of baffling that it's it's
that it works you know
um so you know for them it took a little
bit of convincing but like that moment
and the moment where I was sitting in a
room and I was looking around at the
people that were around me and I was
like and I realized that I had watched
all of these people yes yes
growing like growing up these are people
like that I admired a lot like like
um early content creators like uh like
some names
like JonTron and and and and and a lot
of animators like specifically like like
new grounds like like the early
animation space like like uh psychic
Pebbles and and like these these people
who like they have uh a show on um Adult
Swim now uh smiling friends which is
hilarious and just just being in a room
with these people and and and realize
and feeling like a peer as opposed to
like yes
um as opposed to just like a you know
somebody who I don't know if you were a
fan it's like it's cool and it's it's
even with Colin like I remember hearing
Colin's name a long time ago like
because he got in trouble for like a
mass effect thing ages ago uh and I
remember reading I remember reading that
article at the time and being like
this is complete I have no problem with
this I don't know why people are up this
guy's ass I don't know I don't know
what's going on and then to you know
seven years later do a show with them
it's it's funny it's just like fun like
these these serendipitous moments that
feel like the world is really small are
like weirdly rewarding for whatever
reason and I I I I love it yeah it's
surreal right because it's like you said
a lot of them it appears you watch and
you're like okay and then when you you
get to that moment and it's like they're
a colleague right and there's a boy when
you just sit there like you know I
remember I was watching it would it
would be like it would be like going to
your favorite artist's wedding yeah you
know and you're just like what what am I
doing yeah facts like training your
brain differently yeah you don't come
off like that the dude that was watching
them before right right exactly like you
can you gotta tailor you also can't let
it get to your head too because it's
like I've seen that happen to people and
it's like really sad but like yeah but
um no it's it's it's it's that stuff
where it's like this is wild
man see and I love having those moments
of when yell inside the room and you're
talking a little grouped up you know
because your little Halos all over the
place you just look over the other Silo
and you're like yeah
yeah and seeing the same thing with with
friends of I like seeing Cog and Phil
Spencer sitting exercise like what is
going on
from any of the people on one degree
there's a small world really a small
world man I remember like my first LSM
event and I we came down we did the
dinner
and um it was a bad shout out to Dustin
and uh the mayor at the time you know it
uh it was cool
[Music]
I'm podcasting and this guy's the mayor
of the town and then there's Colin hen
it's Chris and I told you I was like bro
for you to be that young and as talented
as you are is amazing to me yeah I told
you that remember we were saying that
the um what you call the little what was
it the little after hours I call it the
after hour little spots
I like to speak easy yeah that was
hilarious to me because Ben was you know
Ben the mayor Ben I was like and he's
like oh yeah the Speakeasy they could go
down and speak easy that's mine too yeah
and if and if you're hungry you can go
down the block to the um to the brewery
yeah it's a slash restaurant that's mine
too
mayor Nucky Thompson
I love that I can tell exactly where
you're from just by the way you say
hilarious hilarious
said New York
some Bronx none of your address there's
a little bit of BX or no yeah well I uh
yeah I grew up on I grew I split my time
a lot between
um the city
um Yonkers uh and uh and my grandmother
lived on on Gun Hill Road
for real
none of them places
definitely not a misnomer yeah yeah and
you just learning to fight now
[Laughter]
dude Gun Hill Road was wild yeah I I I I
really I I could not I couldn't believe
that my my tiny grandmother lived there
unfazed like it blew my mind like she
would walk down six floors every day in
her in that that old their old building
and she would like walk those streets
and it's just like I remember I have a
distinct memory I'll never forget this I
was on my way my parents my parents
picked me up from from my grandmother's
house on Gun Hill it was it was it was
it was um actually across from um the
park just before
um uh just before it was like the park
Gun Hill and then like the Train on
moshula yeah I don't know what park
you're talking about yeah yeah and uh
you know I was getting out and my
parents picked me up I got in the car
and we hit the end of the road uh where
the train comes and we were gonna make a
left to get to go to uh go back home to
Yonkers and I turned to my right and
there are three people
beating up a pay phone with their bare
fists
and I remember and I remember like just
looking over us I looked at my dad
and I was like what's going on and he
was like just don't worry about it
listen guys in the Bronx yeah when I
tell y'all they out of the Bronx
when King was like yeah we got to show
you the other the other place in New
York now you don't Manhattan in New
Jersey is fine New Jersey I'll show you
the Bronx it's fine we say where we came
from nah I'm good I'm good
yo now you know why people Deckers I'm
not exchanging people beating up a pay
phone for me okay I'm good laid pastimes
in the Bronx
yeah listen as long as you don't have
quarters and you like the Payphone
it's just what got me was the bear fist
man like I look I would have I think
even at my young age I would have
understood like oh they're trying to get
money out of the paper if they were like
if they were hitting it with something
right the idea that they were punching
it yes wow
what kind of Dragon Ball nonsense
what kind of Chris Redfield
insanity is going on and so so like yeah
I mean I I there's a lot of experiences
you have growing up in the Bronx are you
referring to a Christian hit that big
shot
yeah yeah he punches a ball that's what
it was like it was like watching a bunch
of Chris redfields attack a paper he
really didn't deserve it
the people that I'm supposed to the
people that I'm supposed to go see are
running like way like Okay Okay cool so
I've got I got at least uh probably like
an hour all right so what we do what we
do is every uh guest in the round we
gotta do the tradition you know what I'm
saying so I need more Chris ray guns I
think I know one of these the answer to
one of these but I need to hear it live
you have top five video games or
franchises of all time and why
oh wow okay so
top top five okay you can take a
singular video game or you could take a
franchise I'm not gonna do franchise
that's that's the easy way that's super
odd yeah yeah
Shadow Colossus is is my number one it's
it's always been I love I love Shadow
the closet I think that game's just
beautiful I'm playing it again actually
uh I started again last night and I just
I forgot how gorgeous that is the Remake
is crazy yeah the Remake is it's
wonderful it looks amazing but that's a
game that's crazy because I remember
playing shot of the classes in 2013 on
the PS3 like the upres version that was
the first time that was the first time I
played it and it blew my mind then yes
like way after the scale of the Colossus
that sense of scale that sense of scale
is still to this day like I I yeah I've
never seen like there's no game that
that that has nailed it in that same way
like I think God of War 3 kind of comes
like with like some of the things but
it's a different type of scale like
there's something about like just seeing
it get closer and closer as you approach
[__] and then like it's just towering
and then the fact that it's the bosses
are Level design you know what I mean
like like the like the design of the
bosses is it's its own level in some way
it's so cool yeah um
but so it's it's I would say that I
would say definitely the Halo 3
um it's just it's too formative it's too
formative for me to just ignore it's
it's too cold so I still I still play
Halo 3 every now and again go talk um
um
this is so difficult uh
to save time like this is this is gonna
this is an insane one it was cool and I
under and I understand
uh but crash team racing naughty dog
I'm not good there
for whatever reason their first Kart
Racer that they ever made was cracked I
don't know what the hell they were it
was it was broken in the best like that
crash team racing is like the Smash
Brothers Melee of of car it's it's it's
broken it's ridiculous it's the most
competitive car racer I've ever played
like by like by a mod by a mile no attic
you know who goes hard for that I think
BG goes hard for crafty race if I
remember he's he's another one that's on
that train he likes pretty much all cart
racing to be honest with you though so
we got crash team racing okay and uh and
uh I would say three right now I would
say Bioshock is in there of course of
course Bioshock is a is a is absolutely
a classic and honestly I feel like
number five would would change a lot
depending on how you're feeling but but
lately
lately I'm feeling very I'm feeling prey
a lot like I like prayed the prey was
crazy prey was insane to me and it still
blows my mind but like that I mean that
could change like obviously like this
list
but generally like generally I would say
like Halo 3 and Shadow classes are
always there they're always at the top
like like there's they're never not
there no doubt and the final question
favorite console of all time and why
it's a pretty close tie between the PS1
and the 360 to me yeah and I think the
360 honestly gets a lot of um gets a lot
of points in my book because it died on
me three times and I still love it
so like if if anything else had done
that I would easily hate it you know
like if if my
if my switch died on me three times no
way would I love that thing you know
like it's like okay big deal breath of
the wild cool
I like breath of the wild but like not
enough to buy the same machine three
times
360. but the key is you said it's
interesting because PlayStation wasn't
one of my favorite PlayStations so like
yps went over the like most people say
hey PS2 you know like why PS1 I have a
lot of fond memories with PS2 but like
and honestly like obviously Shadow class
is a PS2 game and that's like you know
my favorite game ever but I I think um
just the PS2 was dominated for me by by
Dragon Ball it was like my dragon ball
machine it was it was Budokai it was
Budokai Tenkaichi it was like all this
stuff and then like the occasional
um the occasional like random uh random
platformer attacking the power of Juju
or something yeah that's something weird
but I didn't I I missed in the PS2 era I
missed all of the bit like I never
played Jack and Daxter I never played oh
um I never played Ratchet and Clank
until like the PS4 I didn't I didn't
like a lot middle Gear Solid Metal Gear
Solid even like I I played dude I played
Metal Gear Solid two
um for the first time all the way
through on on the Vita
and so like that generation I was mostly
on the Xbox because it just had like for
whatever reason it was it was AKA it was
it was the Halo it was it was not only
just Halo but it was just it was Halo it
was Hunter the Reckoning it was it was
um it was uh um
his Xbox shot he shot it right now it's
Xbox dude I I I there was something
about the Xbox that felt um alien to me
like it felt cool to have it like it was
this big it was Heavy it was like like
what is it it was green when you left it
on it would have those weird like NASA
like people
and it's just like there's something
enticing about it whereas like the PS2
um was really it was it was really cool
too but like I I fell in love with the
PS1 with like body language
the PS1 I just it was a lot of really
important games for me like like uh ape
Escape those crash bandico games the
Spyro games ape Escape Is Amazing by the
way like I I know oh my god king loves
Vape Escape I love ape Escape dude it's
it's uh it's underrated as hell I think
it's like it's so sad
[Music]
it was and it was like what's crazy
about it too is like it's early Symphony
of the Night Like This is an amazing
time despite the fact that it was like
the the first like foray into 3D so like
those are kind of janky and awkward no
Chris you really know why like the the
PlayStation one well the bottom of the
disc was black
no because remember when you picked it
up it just looked like space yeah yeah
yeah yeah he was like oh yo because all
all the DVDs at that time from or CDs at
the time it was silver oh yeah yeah and
they had like I don't know they was they
was acting like it was like security
protected yeah ah yes my PlayStation
it was all those things like the first
three tekkens Tony Hawkins
uh never soft never soft Spider-Man
games
just like there were so many games on
the PS1 that felt like magic to me and
and and and the PS2 you know and maybe
this was just kind of my fault honestly
it was just with how it was playing but
it was it was mostly just like the
Dragon Ball
and then but yeah I would say PS1 and
that startup sound is still like the
best yeah
I have I have yet to hear a better story
I think one of the most memorable
startups for me was like the gang Cube
because you could twist it if you use it
okay yeah yeah it was it was weird today
yeah but the GameCube I don't know
because the thing is like
I'm 29 now right so when I was when I
was a kid the game going from the Xbox
right where it was like this this like
Rome like this is crazy and then the
even the PS2 was like ethereal it had
like this kind of like um baby kind of
like otherworldly scent and then you go
to the GameCube and it's like
it's like it felt like like I love much
respect to the game do you like I love
melee like like metal arms glitch in the
system like all these like like I love
the GameCube but for whatever reason
that startup sound made me feel like a
baby all right yeah but one thing you
could say though even though it was it
was unorthodox like you could definitely
you know the difference like oh yeah the
last GameCube oh yeah you know I hate
when you can hold it and it has the baby
sound
[Music]
like
tremendous game in history we got to get
into some topics man we're gonna do it
let's do it so if you want to get you
gotta get a couple of these yeah
stage member for two years five dollar
Super Chat this is French coat addict
going to run around packs Commando whoa
and screaming come play with my joystick
where you at yo he went left
this reminds me this reminds me like I
did a podcast a long time ago where a
friend of ours this is before we had
video but she was dressed and I don't
think she meant this but she was dressed
like a minion no
she had like a yet like a bright yellow
a bright yellow long shirt and then like
like denim overalls did she just come
back from like work or something and I
was like why do you look at me and we
spent the whole the whole episode of
making fun of her sort of looking like a
minion absolute
so look out for addict on the show floor
paxis
[Music]
I'm gonna have like the trip pants on
yeah be great continue sir we got Robert
Kellen two dollar Super Chat CTR is
legit put a ton of hours into the PS4
version okay it's a good remake too like
they really nailed they kept all the
broken stuff I was worried they were
gonna fix it they were trying to make
like we gotta make it we gotta make it
uh uh smooth and accessible it's like no
that game is still cracked it's wake
it's way it's more cracked now actually
so Props to them for not fixing what's
not broken you know there you go there
we have to meet remember for one year
two dollar Super Chat salute to the
Lords welcome to the realm Chris
appreciate it
then we have heartachini once again
member for 20 months Lord gold tell me
you're covering how PlayStation is
scared that the Xbox will be with that
the the Xbox will behave the way they do
yeah and their remedies response to the
CMA and how Jim lion crying flying hold
on Jim line crying flying dance moves
Ryan doesn't want a card deal that's all
right hockey be a super messy today yeah
casares fifteen dollars if we chat the
real question how many of you would it
take to to down a gorilla on steroids
what are we doing wow what are we doing
oh my God
hold his legs
it reminds me of Love there was like
this Tick-Tock train going around I
think you made a a tick tock about it
Chris where it's like how many how many
two Euros could you fight before they
took you
oh I don't know like this is like an
ancient Quest like oh it's always is
like how like how many like ninth grade
or like how many fourth graders do you
think you could take fourth grade or
something like that or like I don't know
man
enough how about that that's why enough
that's that's my answer
sounds like it sounds like it sounds
like Derek undercover again yeah yeah
yeah
it's like a much to start take debated
question it sounds like a Derek thing
where he's like we should I don't
understand why we don't have just why
don't we just why we don't just give
gorillas steroids and have them fight
and it's just like
I'm sure
I'm sure a group of
I've been fighting
I think the idea is just like a mat like
gorilla's fighting is already impressive
but now imagine them twice
Barry Bonds gorillas
getting limbs getting ripped off with
the savagery continue so I think that's
it all right cool patreon questions real
quick shout out to Tao in the chat Hello
Lord I want to ask you what do you think
about the state of games and have co-op
in them as someone who tries to play
with his brothers and niece games either
have local but no online co-op or um not
to mention three player co-op I believe
Destiny just saying Co-op seems to be a
thing of the past thoughts anyone are
you talking about Nintendo games
yeah I mean in the way that they used to
be I guess it's different for sure uh
obviously like
we used to have more reliable split
screen obviously Halo not having split
screens is insane in Co-op but uh you
know I there's still a ton like I I
would argue we've gotten some of the
best like it takes two I thought was
awesome
I think we need more experiences like
that like yeah it takes two yeah
Joseph as far as literally handling
myself yeah I I prefer Co-op where like
both individuals are written into the
story yeah Resident Evil five uh you
know it takes two a ways out like I
don't like when they just like make a
clone of yourself yeah
I'm with you in that salute I guess it's
all about what makes money right now and
um if your game is built up from Co-op
from the ground up yet but
this nobody cares about couch Co-op it's
a very Niche group so the statistics say
yeah you know it's just not viable yeah
they're usually analytics I think and
you you know what's crazy
the fact that Joseph was able to
convince EA to like yo they just got to
buy my game once that's all they just
got about my game once they can they can
do the friend little share thing that's
all and EA was like sure but that's the
only way that you can it was successful
too that's the crazy it was successful
yeah look man yay uh you know it's not
we're we're they're a different EA yeah
they used to be not that different in
favor they're definitely better like I
mean that Dead Space remake is amazing
so like I would since they upgraded HR
department yeah yeah
I would compare this I would compare
this to like Capcom in the 360 era like
they they changed their image going
through now now it's activations
they got that PlayStation bag that's all
so if you was good with the uh local
co-op because I I said which is a bit
like switch my thing is I think switch
kind of keeping the tradition going
which keeps it the tradition but like my
nephew plays online uh fortnite with his
friends all the time so and they'll do
it when they're like they get in the
same room with each other they'll Place
Mass like that so switch is keeping it
alive on PlayStation and and Xbox I
don't really see it as being viable man
like for me it's just everybody's
playing online and that's just what it
is you know second question I made shout
out to stitch hey Lords I know we are
tired of hearing about the ABK deal
however based on the comments provided
by Lulu this week about Jim not wanting
a new deal he just wants to block the
merger on how on how damaged do you how
damaged do you feel think the
relationship between ABK and Sie is at
this point two that's one and then two
how difficult would it be for seie to
acquire another Studio or publisher
after everything they have said thank
you see you Sunday thoughts anyone yeah
I think they're in nuclear mode you know
I think they saw a glimp of hope that
they could shut this down so now they've
just hit the nuke but they're like we
don't care what we damaged I don't care
how people feel about us you know we
number one in the in the industry and we
gonna make everyone think we the number
of the last place
shout out to my Asian sister
she outside
she's doing it I don't know man like I
think it's it's they're in it I mean
Sony it's weird because they're they're
being really annoying like somebody's
been annoying me this whole time like
okay this this whole because like I'm
like I the oh exclusivity and stuff but
it's like dude you you lock so much
behind it's not I understand it's not
the same thing as like right Call of
Duty but it's still like there's a
reason why I feel like we're not hearing
a lot of Sony right now generally and I
think it's because a lot of the stuff
that they have to show is exclusive and
it's not going to look good generally
they didn't do nothing last year because
they yeah 100 show that event
and I honestly feel like that might be
the reason Microsoft did the 12 month
thing last year because they didn't want
to go beyond that and look bigger than
they actually are too so they're both
playing cards yeah and and yeah yeah and
the thing is like Sony's in a really
good position right now because they
could say whatever they want really and
and they know they're going to get Call
of Duty like they they it would be dumb
of Microsoft not to put Call of Duty on
Playstation it makes so much money it's
like it would be it would just be very
dumb of them so they're just like yeah
we could say whatever what are you gonna
do take it away are you really yeah I
mean Lulu was calling it out so Jim was
like we blocking it regardless whatever
we don't care what we said I was like
yeah yeah I mean people are giving Jim
sure for that but it's like it's so
clearly that's what that's so obviously
like what it was always we just want to
block the merger
I don't care what you off I just don't
want you to get it
I don't want you happy my main my my
main source of frustration with all this
and I've said this on on sacred too is
is like um Activision is clearly in a
position where they're looking to sell
you know and and they're looking for
Acquisitions in some way and my concern
is if Microsoft doesn't get them
the obvious answer is 10 cent because
there's nobody else who's big enough
exactly Talk That Talk fire Activision
so like I'm like dude I would absolutely
much rather Microsoft have them than 10
cent have them yeah that's what I'm
saying I'm sure like and actually the
other potential big players aren't even
in it now like we I just saw that
Stadium like the stadia tech they just
killed that too yeah it's gone the tech
isn't even viable to anyone so it's one
of those graveyards exactly so it's not
not even like they're out of it
completely so yeah the answer is tensa
yeah and and that's I don't know like
now let Microsoft get that's what Tim
said was like three four Microsoft they
have that no it is interesting I'm glad
I'm glad you guys brought that up
awesome you got that last one I'll get
the poll why oh I get the poll yeah we
got we got two more we have uh Joe Repco
AKA blaming the building salute like
that's fine it's five dollar Super Chat
good afternoon IOP salute to the
legendary Chris Reagan let Starfield
cooked because Halo didn't and please
for the love of square play octopath
review out right now my voice
got that octopath two review go check
that out continue okay well let me let
me ask you a question about octopath is
it is it a final fantasy situation where
like I do I have to play the first one
no I don't think you do no I don't know
it seems like to me because I haven't
played it it's an another set of
characters and like another set of uh
stories yeah maybe I don't know though
it might be like the grandson of the
first ones like yeah yeah yeah I'll
figure it out but maybe I'll jump into
it I've always wanted it I it's I've
always wanted to get into those games I
know but there's just something that's
good though it is uh I remember last
year in Nintendo release live alive or
whatever that game
is what I feel like
octopath is like a so much higher
quality game in that game and people
said no hey you're gonna love live life
you're gonna love it and I played I was
like what were they smoking flame said
you don't need to play the first one
completely different level than this
game shot the flight he said you don't
need to play the first one Chris he said
you're good okay cool yeah no maybe I'll
give it a shot or maybe the first one's
worth I don't know I gotta I gotta I
gotta sort how I feel about it so and we
have Mr Irishman five pound stupid chat
start the week with Buddha kaitenkachi 4
being announced and get to end it with
watching you guys it's definitely been a
good one thank you brother no doubt no
doubts hello I really I had friends
calling me from elementary school
I got a call I was like did you see
now bro is out yeah that's like a hockey
wrestling game yeah came outside to make
a new recipe man we'd be outside but
especially what I liked about the
tinkaichi franchise is like the the
destruction you can blow up like whole
they'll be like little things in space
that you blow up the whole thing and now
you're not fighting on ground anymore
you're just floating around yeah
you could you could destroy the planet I
think and you just be floating in space
which is like really you know selfish
and then they'll be they'll be joking
like they're sparring and they just
killed a billion people yeah exactly we
got three more all right
let's go yeah Tom from Toonami ten
dollars should we chat Lulu said I'm
gonna bring the Ruckus look right at Jim
and said you better protect your neck
then walked out the room saying ABK Clan
Ain't Nothing to Africa
much love good to see you and thanks for
hooking me up with the audio settings
yes sir and we got Dragonheart Yobe five
dollars Super Chat I saw an article last
uh an article last and it's stated
Square Enix is releasing blockchain
games in the future just sell those IPS
off and flush them into yeah would be
crazy if if the active version Dale
doesn't go through it Microsoft's like
I'm just going to buy Square Enix and
they somehow manage that like imagine
the internet if they bought Square Enix
that would be a very fun day on Twitter
yeah you just want to see the messiness
all
I generally want that to happen the 10
down the last one Nintendo yeah
apparently I violated nine ten down deal
Taco five dollars say it with me
tenkaiichi damn that attic outdo you and
pronounce it pronunciated
it's it's pronouncing things not
pronouncing wait wait wait have I been
have I been saying you're wrong
I think they were talking to Saul
yeah it's Budokai Tenkaichi okay okay
that's how I used to say it I might be
wrong I don't know maybe it's because we
played it sounds like yeah
it's one of those things though but
because they don't say it ever
so like it it's only on the it's only
the name of the game they never say that
word ever so like I don't know so it's
inferred as a pronunciation
but it could be wrong
and the Man Comes thank you for your
five dollars
when you call me on pronunciation and
you say pronunciating things oh
this is at the time too where like every
name was at the title screen you click
Resident Evil
they never say that particular we got G
pocket ability he said that is the
correct pronunciation salute G G
co-siders
but I I forgive me for pronunciating it
incorrectly
don't ever do it all right the people
spoken um with Sony's potentially forced
to detail PlayStation exclusivity deals
to the FTC and Xbox which of these
potential scenarios do you think Sony
would value the most the winner of the
four-way ILP poll at 49 of the vote was
blocking third party titles from Xbox
game pass coming in at second with 30 of
the vote was extended length of
PlayStation exclusivity contracts group
in third place with 12 percent of the
vote was the messy Lords I don't care
Sony still gonna block this deal anyway
and in last place with a close seven
percent of the vote was marketing rights
on the biggest third-party game Saw 49
of the vote said they are 30 they
believe that the Saudi values blocking
third party titles off Game Pass
thoughts I think that's a big yes
according to the gym listen I really
want to see the ins and outs of this
document and really see where because
again I really like we've been saying
it's just it's it's a messy business
everybody's a hypocrite it's just I it's
funny they I mean they had to know that
this was going to have to come out and
the hypocrisy was going to be out on the
table for everyone to say you you know
it would be crazy if you find out that I
thought that was gonna happen yeah I
don't think they did either like but I
think that they I think they thought
that they would get subpoenaed for it
but I think they generally thought they
could avoid giving it like I I think
they knew it was gonna happen I just
don't think they care because they know
that it doesn't matter listen Chris it's
the confidential Witnesses don't ever
again
about them not caring that is that's
that's the point yeah that's at the end
I think the reason then the reason that
they're they're that they keep you know
debating The subpoena and like delaying
uh the findings is just like them buying
them more time
I think so 100 but I don't know this
this whole thing is
insane I'm excited I'm excited to see
whatever is in these documents because
these people in the Bronx you from the
Bronx none of that you don't do none of
that snitch injury
show Chris the mug
you're being clean you got the emo the
Emojis up the Emojis up right now we
have a mug that's to stop snitches
he ain't down with that sitting there he
said
this he said him and Colin went to a
bistro but the pizza shop was right next
to him
New York it hurts I can't now with him
I'm with them they continue
I'm just saying like usually I'm gonna
say usually when we get these when we
get these types of document leaks the
last time I can remember anything
happening uh related this was another
Activision situation a long time ago I
don't know if you guys remember this
when a big Call of Duty lawsuit was
happening and we got leaks about like
what Destiny was gonna do oh yes yes yes
yes it's been like maybe like 2012 2011
something like that and and um you know
it's we learned a lot of interesting
stuff out of that and so like this is
going to be a you know oh yeah
nothing I'm just saying it's gonna be
out there
all right star field uh but that's the
star field uh shout out to tell Warren
and The Verge put the news out
um will now be released September
sixth the latest up topic telling title
for Microsoft owned bethesda's getting
that new release they also announced
that the uh star field direct event will
now be on June 11th that's the same day
I believe as the Microsoft Bethesda Xbox
because it should have came out I'm
Gonna Let You Go first I know this is
contentious so um yeah they just set up
in the event Todd how we got how it came
out there he said in June we're going to
bring you into the studio and give you a
deep dive in the game at our Starfield
direct there's so much that we still
have to show you the dedicated stall
field event will be again follow the
annual showcase that event Jordan 11
which has caused a bit of a buzz and
controversy on Twitter and there's a lot
of feelings and you know I think King
has been very prophetic about his
feelings and dropped the early dish
record on Twitter about what is to come
so I'm gonna shut up because this is
what the realm waited for they said [__]
shut up let him get his balls off and I
think we'll all go after kicks okay
now that we have the date of our star
field
and we know how you feel prior how's
this how you resonated right now
I was going to do
um a battle rap
I I literally was gonna start it off
with like time time time and and just go
into a whole battle rap and then I was
just like nah that's corny and then you
realize how much time
I don't listen to you damn trench coat
Mafia I don't listen to you leave my man
alone he took it off though
he didn't take it oh yeah he said I'd
rather have hard nipples I slap my
fingers and it just disappeared
um
and then then I go back and I looked I
looked at that uh that showcase three
times three times I went back and looked
at the Showcase 30 games this hasn't
been done in 20 years you know the 12
month thing then I watched the podcast
over again I watch podcast right after
and Saul was like that's an unnecessary
rate and I'm like man shut up
in the corner I'm like oh man shut up
[Laughter]
no it's just all about the Kool-Aid
stuff came like okay it's all about yeah
I'm sorry having respect for for those
people because you know Microsoft is a
kid that you see him trying hard but he
just don't have that athleticism you
know he's on the baseball team but he
don't have like you know you got the
Derrick Jeeps everything come easy to
them you know and they're getting the
accolades and they're trying but he
trying hard too you know sometimes he
stumbles like he's running to the base
and he's going real hard because he
practice all week but he tripped right
at the end you know like he get called
out you know but Microsoft was always
trying
this is all on you bro I told you make
your date
um
30 games you showed
10 of them don't got dates
that's the hell of a l bro that is a
hell of an L I don't and and I don't
care don't tell me oh you know we we
took the time out for the 30 to the you
know it was Todd ready before it was
Todd ready last year right
and everybody knew
going in that you put a Target on your
back now I know you're gonna say oh we
don't have control over third-party
Studio games like stalker 2.
we don't have control over Hollow Knight
we don't have control
then you shouldn't have put 12 months up
yeah
you let's say that person that went in
and said oh snap 12 months that's what
I'm gonna get I'm gonna pay my 12 months
of Game Pass right now
and they counted on those 12 months like
you said those games are going to be
there you didn't get on stage and say we
estimate
now one time that was later when the
Tweet went out estimated was at the
bottom but when you was on stage and
let's say I'm Ray Charles
that I didn't read the fine print
but I just listened to the show on the
podcast right and you said
12 months this is what you're gonna play
all right
and everybody's rallying behind you it
was a great show it was a hell of a show
but 10 of the most important games are
right there but other games are there
but the 10 most important games the 10
pillars of your show ain't in there so
who's the L for the L is for you I told
you you was going to get this smoke
Starfield slip you're gonna get this
work where the hell is Forza so
obviously if Starfield is in September
where the hell what's for the date
oh it looks 60 frames you thought you
was gonna shut me up because it looks 60
frames give it a Todd 30 like Todd said
and get it out and give the patch
because you know you know Cog and saw
with this man said release to the 30
frames listen I don't I don't care I
don't care about this you don't care if
the game runs yeah
on this because
so you ain't gonna have it both way at
it you're not gonna say oh I want just
the results I don't care what what is
holding you up I don't care what is
wrong I don't you told me 12 months and
I think the measure of a company and the
measure of the people is
how they stick to their work I supported
you this whole time I'm the one to have
faith remember I'm the one to put up a
picture or tweet
they said I think it's going to launch
on time so I got to Front Line this
right you didn't come out and say yo you
know what we definitely messed up keep
mad because he jumped outside
is your professional relationships
affecting this decision yes
you see it right here I think you were
whining and dying with time Howard
Florida yes yes I looked into his baby
blue eyes
and he said to me King don't worry
did not know your time was September
take your time bro stuff you know where
my king was like yo you gotta be a man
of your work you got to be a man you
said 12 months
we saying this to Tom Howard it is
hilarious because King shut me down he's
like yo better be a bunch of words I
love the idea of Todd Howard uh and you
guys are like the angel and devil on his
shoulder like telling him like oh man we
no you gotta make 12 months he's like no
you gotta make sure it's good because
it's a matter of you but he's just like
arguing
no I I mean this this whole look it's
it's it is disappointing to me that they
uh that they are going to miss yet
another date it's it's always irritating
when this happens but to me I'm like bro
don't
don't announce a date until you're sure
you know what I mean like this all of
this stuff could be like I I no longer
assume like anytime somebody's like oh
games coming out April 15th I'm like oh
cool so like September yeah right like
all every time like I always like what's
what's a reasonable delay like four
months something like that okay and I
auto corrected the date to that and it's
usually right like almost all the time
it's like it's actually crazy every game
has been delayed at one point yeah
release dates mean nothing to me now
like because they clearly just announced
them
before they're ready and before they're
even sure that they're going to hit them
and so to me it's to me it's it's not an
issue of pushing the game to September
it's a matter of having that date be
moved so consistently just don't give a
date and people wouldn't have a problem
with this I agree I I I I will always be
in favor of a delay because I've seen
dude the the amount of
the the state that Halo infinite
launching is so unacceptable like I I
really can't I I really can't believe
like how mismanaged that project was
given how important that that that IP is
um
it's a frustrating thing because like
that's it's like a you play you play
Halo infinite it's like this is actually
a great game but it's like damn If Only
They had just given it that extra time
so they could have landed the way it
should have and that game's not really I
I don't see it really recovering ever
maybe
irreparable damage
I heard
you know hey dudes is over there having
fun I don't know man it's fine yeah the
new season where um where the frame rate
issues are happening on Console now
it's a mess man and it's just like it's
again it's not the worst thing that it's
ever been but it like it didn't have to
be this way so like if and Starfield is
the most important game
that Xbox
here continue
that you was going to get 12 months I
agree give me the money back 100 but I
think it's I think it's better for them
to I think it's better for them to
suffer the short-term damage of like
okay we missed the date we missed the
date then it is for them to put this
game out before it's ready when it's
clearly the most important game that
they have right now so refresh yourself
everything
everything is riding on Starfield but I
mean that every week
how I feel I feel like they looked at me
and said how do we keep an idiot and
suspense
here here's my thing with it
good I I do feel like oh
give Microsoft that smoke they did make
they said expectations they uh they gave
you dates that you know realistically
they didn't know they could keep her out
especially from like a third party point
of view but at the same time as much as
I overwhelmingly want the game to come
out more than I care about their dates
like I I want the game to come out not
broken then I care about their day to
come out the best thing to lie to you
and here's here you like them to lie to
you no that's not the that's not the
point I care about the the health of of
Starfield and whether or not this game
comes out in in a busted State a Halo
State more than I care about them
telling me something all right what they
say I want the game to be the best so
the next time you order your food and
they say they will be there in 15
minutes
with your food and get that hour and a
half but they said yo it's gonna be
better though
they said they said to me so is
having someone call me like yo and get
you that food in 15 minutes but it's
gonna be wrong
this is why I order my food three days
before I'm hungry
I don't want to hold these dudes
dude I I care more about Starfield as a
game that I care about what they said I
care more about the lion
don't lie to me and tell me yo if
somebody tell you yo you go to the
mechanic they said your car is going to
be ready tomorrow and it's two weeks
later yo what's up with my car oh
they're like
tomorrow you
drive down the road break like Buster
busted
they gave me half a car
solves up to solve's knowledge of the
game it's gonna come out broken in
September oh it will oh listen I don't
trust September
yeah I I I'm I'm I'm what's up
I would put money I would put money on
September not being I I bet I bet
something's good but like here's here's
the real problem right it's it's
Starfield is like it is it will reshape
how the future looks for the for Xbox if
if Starfield comes out and it's a
botched mess and I'm not talking about
like Bethesda Jane you know like there's
a certain amount of Bethesda Jen that
people are going to appreciate there's
even some that I'm probably like a
little bit excited for to be honest with
you like I like I like that honestly but
if it's if it's busted like beyond
recognition and if it does not meet
expectations and make no mistake
expectations for this game are super
high yes this is like I think I feel
like Starfield is it has come as close
to as talking
the expectations on Starfield are like
nearly like Half-Life 3 levels where
it's like this needs to be this needs to
be great because if it's not then
everybody's gonna be like what the [__]
is going on with Fable then sorry no
sorry Chris again what is going on with
Fable what's going on with Fable like
what the hell's going on with uh but you
don't have Todd on Fable we know what's
happening everybody this is really a
Todd thing
like if I think in Bethesda was allowed
to drink modern bethes to do this thing
would have came out already I I feel
like Microsoft has two lanes that they
got approved for this this game Star for
they got to justify the beginning of all
these these you know these purchases
which is as to why we bought Bethesda we
bought Bethesda for games like Star Phil
uh you know then they got to prove that
you know not only did we buy Bethesda
because I I do think they have to prove
to people why they're investing so much
money into to the ecosystem they also
got approved and we're going to actually
help make a better Bethesda we're we're
going to hear the Fallout 76 illness
that they have and I think that these
two lanes are very rough to navigate
through and all it would take is this
game come out in a real bad state
they're like okay it don't matter they
bought Bethesda they they're going to
make nothing but Fallout 76 for the rest
of our lives and if the game comes out
then okay it doesn't matter they invest
it what's the point in investing into
Activision investing into those Studios
you know the initiative stuff when
they're like they can't even get
Starkville right why can't they get any
of these games right Fable up for
chopping blocks yeah it's going to make
them managing
argument way worse something else
something else to consider too is that
the expectation for Starfield is so high
that even if it is a really good I feel
like people are going to be harsh on it
anyway so it's so it needs to be better
than it needs to be better than amazing
yeah no that's a fact so we're going to
get it that's it's it's it's a rough
it's a yes I do not envy I do not envy
Todd Todd's position absolutely new IP
and all that so your thoughts on this
sir
so so first I must apologizing I
apologize that probably before switching
my thing anytime I I side with King on
anything I fly too close to the Sun
I should have stuck to myself talk I had
a really bad yes
and Todd is like yo my I know my
audience my audience know I'm gonna come
with a little bit of Jank
like y'all saying right now the talk
that I have
oh this game has to be God it can't miss
it's actually it is never going to hit
those expectations whatever the
expectations are there's going to be
some people out there one or two people
that's gonna be like this is the
greatest game to ever hit this Earth and
they're going to be fighting people over
it but the majority of the people is
going to be like it's a good that's the
game it's a good fall I like Fallout 2
better than that's when the whole
comments is going to start coming out
but it's never going to reach those
lofty expectations you say Fallout 2
yeah he did but we gonna move on
his love for this series
so yeah like so so Chris for context
like I you know I had normal take that
that's a clue normal people
and drop it in the fall and that's it
right but I I got excited by Hi-Fi rush
I'll be honest I I felt that there was a
confidence I'm like wait a minute they
dropping this I'm like I thought Russia
was awesome yes it was absolutely so out
of nowhere and they gave you that
because they knew they wasn't giving you
the rest of those games one thing I
knocked them for is that they they don't
know how to do the mic drop moment the
real mic drop moment the way PlayStation
likes to drop mics they don't really do
that well and I'm like maybe they have
it here they so confident Hi-Fi Rush
so how was it I think we're gonna get
Starfield we're gonna it'll be March
April
this is all backtrack yeah I love this
it's great
I'm making I'm acknowledging these these
two killed me it would be dude
September either
and I will go back to it these games a
bgs game could literally be worked on
forever and not be bug free
100 like no no I agree it was gonna come
out whatever whenever because according
to kick it don't matter when it releases
I'm going back I'm going I'm going back
to where I belongs
is that the Kool-Aid
and Chris said it perfectly and I've
said this a million times as well it has
to be a business consideration why they
keep putting dates onto these games that
do not they know full well they're not
gonna hit it doesn't make any sense to
me because you just keep looking bad
just don't put a date on it you know
what it is though let's be real like
they went into last year and people
saying yo we want more game playing we
want dates we want game playing we want
dates and I think they their mindset's
like we don't know if this game can
realistically hit this this this time
frame that's why they didn't give Street
dates they just gave a time period but
we got to tell them some form of time
period because if they would have came
on stage last year let's be real and
gave a bunch of games with no time frame
whatsoever they would have they would no
one would have carried anything
if they show if they show gameplay this
excite excites me I don't really care
about the day now but people it's at
explore I think people would have been
like yo no they would have been
obliterated here's the thing people
probably would have but the issue is the
issue isn't even necessarily putting a
date on things before you know that
you're ready to put it out the issue is
showing your games too early in the [__]
in the first place you know like it is
like why why did you talk about the next
Elder Scrolls three years ago like don't
do that
how long ago did we see the first teaser
trailer three years ago it was it three
years
twenty it is 2023
yeah I'd rather complete silence and
shock me six months before the game's
about to come out
we we saw a vowed uh I mean we we have
some form of hope that you know maybe
hellblade's end of the year beginning of
next year but you know that's not even
really
oh okay
you know what to be honest King with
your track record I wouldn't believe it
either you can stop trying to come for
me put your trench coat back on
my father
please I'll scare you back um
the problem is I don't I don't trust
them anymore I don't trust them why all
right this is the only industry where
they could give you a date and we're
we're cool with it right and they can
switch it up we don't take that from
anything you Uber five minutes late he
was just getting one star right
literally yo y'all don't settle for this
in nothing your girl upstairs getting
ready and she's like yeah I'll be down
in 10 minutes an hour later you walk
Furious y'all in the car you're not
talking you're just driving what you got
to get to oh could you tell your wife
that you're gonna get married September
6 and even like nah we're gonna do this
in December
ultimate will have 30 games for all
these games Star field red for
everything I'm gonna be playing Forza in
the next 12 months what if he only got
12 months to live
no yeah it came the
the dinosaurs
dinosaurs and then everybody was silver
that Jordan yeah I don't think it's not
that crap that you talking about no
where's Hollow Knight where's Flintlock
it's it's mad games I went back look now
it's like oh yeah y'all slick so right
now I feel like how do you keep an idiot
in suspense you tell them 12 months
and then and then when you got no other
recourse when you gonna announce your
show in June this is the only reason why
we got September date because oh the
show was going to be in June why because
you want to protect Diablo
you know the the better thing we could
talk about too is the fact that that
showcase is the same day yeah that's
concerned
that might be in that showcase and take
a look
me to me why would you do it the same
day why why wouldn't you do it before
going into the show unless you you're
gonna direct people a lot of the hype's
going to be at that towards that show
like well you feel they're gonna have
less you think they're gonna have
lessons they're gonna have less I feel
like they might not have a like
the the stuff that they necessarily want
to show and they're going to direct some
of of that height towards it it's okay
you know we we showed you this and I
know some of you might like it some of
you might not but we got the Starfield
thing in 30 40 minutes that you can yeah
like six months
are you gonna do it before the show
that's like a pre-show that I'll okay I
can understand that a little bit but if
it's afterwards
to me what is why why are you gonna have
something like that after the show to
take away from the spotlight of your
show like yeah we got to see I mean I'll
jump in if I if I can't talk
I'm done yeah look
um
from a pure predictable standpoint we're
not King is right from a pure principle
standpoint yeah just the principle of it
yeah yeah
I get that you know what I'm saying into
Chris's point this is all self-inflicted
like you have no business going out
there saying
that whatever you see here is gonna for
the next 12 months you're gonna get and
that's why if you remember cog's been on
the record when everybody's like yo that
12 book format is fun no it's not fired
because the reason why I don't like it
is one you take away the Wonder and the
mic drop moments like solve is talking
about the magic that could happen right
that's what make a Nintendo yo I can't
believe they drop you know what I'm
saying at the end same thing with the
Sony League all men so I I hated that
then you put undue pressure that these
games better come out in the 12
otherwise you're gonna have King out
here doing with King do making this
recognition with unnecessary pressure
that could have been completely right
away now where King loses me is games
get delayed every day B like like like
literally you know what I'm saying so
like God Awards I feel that but Timmy
died Waiting for God of War Ragnarok in
so Timmy died waiting for Zelda breath
two in 2022.
Timmy's dying a lot
you know that that's a TV show right now
bad sitcom people waiting for today
it's just the same it's just the same
child waiting and dying before a video
game comes out it's like a graveyard of
dead Timmy
rest in peace Timmy x uh
Frank
[Laughter]
come on let's be real make a wish Timmy
is using that lamp for Spider-Man 2
instead of Starfield let the boy die
with his smile
y'all regrets look man
the health and quality over the game
yeah comes over people's feelings
over taking pictures with people
[Laughter]
comes over that tweet on the title on
the screen you know
look they messed up they did they didn't
they didn't execute their target as king
said you want to say lion absolutely
right but at the end are they rightful
to get the smoke they're rightful to get
it because self-inflicted but this is my
thick when I watch The Joint
I'm looking at what I see and what I see
I look over Todd's shoulder okay now
what I remember what I recall
there was a lot of 30 frames per second
energy
in the first one and the first time we
saw it I mean it's like damn now that
part right there with the combat I don't
know you know what I'm saying everything
else yeah grandiose this oh you got
space cop okay
we did a crossover we was like What if
it's 30 though and you were like bro I
don't know if I could do this 30. and I
cannot you know what I'm saying so for
me
I look at what I just saw
and I'm like you saw that Runner he
looked like some 60 FPS I don't know I
saw a lot of Xbox controllers in front
of PCS hey I just liked it it was moving
faster than what it was moving before I
mean I think I think we all could I I
think the uh you know the the master
race knows that it was going to run 60
on PCS not Howard is going to announce
35.
everybody oh they can do the 41 because
y'all
engage engage vrr you know
so look at the end of the day that's
about that you know what I mean and I
hate the code for for y'all but do not
let this game be a 90 plus meta critic
do not let this game I mean fire I am
going to be on y'all because for all
every time
if all this smoke after y'all they learn
from Halo infinite and this game get
delayed it's actually fired it's a game
of the year Contender I want all of
y'all to keep the same energy I want you
through the same energy stand on your
Square support not by don't pick it up
but we over there celebrating popping
bottles you don't pick it up you're not
allowed all y'all can play is
unacceptable you can't do it this is I
gotta standard go to change.org and say
we are not buying this game despite the
90s because they should have kept their
word and we will be over there playing
for the game of the years
everybody Under the Sun is going to
review this game and that only brings
the number down
all I'm saying is
great I'm happy if it's an 80 seconds
if it is and this is God Howard brown
leather jacket Skyrim energy I won't be
looking for y'all the same dude man I'm
on life support right here all I hear is
questions
[Laughter]
so yeah that's pretty much that let's uh
combine this joint and then we'll read
the super chest after the election right
shout out to Chris for extending that
time thank you I appreciate it because I
needed his thoughts on this so uh yeah
those are broke uh I think this was an
inside gamer that I saw yeah kicking it
I'd eased it back yeah he up to 90 gonna
do this one
new job listing uh suggest that uh Last
of Us multi-player could be coming to
PS4 so the listing is four and associate
multiplayer quality QA tester who states
that the applicant must have working
knowledge of PS4 and PS5 systems
suggesting that The Last of Us
multiplayer will be a cross generation
game so uh yeah this is kind of just
kind of recently broke the information
yeah um Chris what's your thoughts on
this you know cross-generational title
are you upset are you or do you
understand like what's your position on
this
uh it's I mean it's disgusting uh like I
don't I I thought we moved past this you
know like dude we got dead space
running exclusively on next-gen Hardware
you know what I mean like so like what
the next Last of Us multiplayer I think
is going to be a PS4 game that sucks I
I'm not upset I'm not upset by it
because I don't really care that much
about Last of Us in general it's it's
kind of you know it's it's it's a very
you know it's fine to me like it's not
one of my favorite games ever I'll tell
you that much so like the the
multiplayer exclu like this specifically
like oh uh the live service multiplayer
version of it not being like a a pure
PS5 game isn't personally disappointing
to me it's just it's just disappointing
from a
just from a standpoint of like man I
thought I thought we got over this by
now you know like I thought we were at a
point where it's like okay we we
supported it's been three years nah they
said longer though
and we're not reading the fine print we
keep on listening to them yeah I mean I
don't know The Last of Us Part Two is is
a PS4 game and that looks good and I I
assume that the next gen versus just
gonna run better and that's fine I just
like I don't know man I just I just I
want us to get past this weird hurdle
that we're saying I honestly think that
the Xbox is in a weird in a weird spot
with a series S as well yo somebody's
just saying The Last of Us on PS4 is the
series
yo shout out don't send that that is
messy shout out to McFly Walker it's the
series that fault that is yeah
considering we're talking about Tom for
uh Toonami said attic you still share
Spider-Man 2 or PS5 only yeah I'm still
sure 100 million yeah yeah there's the
king's still bending the knee for that
okay Midnight tweet
[Laughter]
Spider-Man 2 is a PS4 game I'm leaving
like I'm not like I'm just not I'm like
not participating in this I'm gonna go
live in the mountains I'm gonna I'm
gonna be a mountain person you're gonna
be out here and start cutting trees down
we're gonna you know what man that's
gonna be the best [__]
I'm already I'm already in the best
shape of everybody keep it going moving
to the mountains down elk or something
um
instead of snow
you're here too
Chris gonna walk you he could look like
Brock Lesnar in the company
I I just yeah I just I don't see why it
would because there's because they've
already
we've already started this if Dead Space
remake is PS5 like I mean there's no
but if it is PS4 man that's gonna be
rough uh I I just it's been the
console's been out for three years you
know like we we have I I if Halo 3 you
know came out and that was that was two
years after the the launch of 360. if
Halo 3 came out and it's like oh it's
still coming out on the original Xbox so
it's limited in that way that would be
disappointing like just straight up it
would it would just it would suck to
know that your that Hardware dude the
Xbox One and PS4 that's 2012 Hardware
yeah yeah 2013 it released in 2013 but
like the specs of that is 2012 and below
and even back then it was underpowered
so the idea of a 2023 Last of Us
multiplayer game being being limited to
that machine is insane and I just I
can't abide by it if that's real that
sucks
Angel Pascal face yeah
uh factions or multiplayer both Last of
Us um potentially PS4 as well
I feel like the reason you're gonna see
this is because I do feel like factions
is going to be on PC day one too
I think so too yeah yeah and I think day
one when you're when you're yeah be
careful when you go on this podcast we
say stuff like this and that's fine
I'm willing to take that bet
it's a live service it is a live service
game it is it is most likely going to be
alive they want they want that
everywhere I feel you with your logic
but on this podcast
that live service gains is going to be
on PC take that back but I'm just I'm
just telling you the community does not
react well because they they feel that
it's never going to be a simultaneous
situation
I mean even if I make that bet you're
just getting one of the knees
but what
yeah there's a lot of there's a lot of
need time
like I feel like I've jumped into like
season six of a show I have not been
watching what's going on let's Game of
Thrones
but you gotta you got to be a manatee
conviction and you think something's
gonna happen and the other Lord say that
something else gonna happen that we make
the BET and then we we come up with the
embarrassment terms for all right yeah
I've never seen Game of Thrones I just I
watched I spend most of my time watching
Seinfeld on repeat okay
he took my knees like last year and I'm
about to take two sets of his knees
conviction rate till I get 50. sir so
I'm just want to know I just wanted to
hear you back down out loud
I just want to hear the Kool-Aid pump
I'll just check that out
I don't know
what the world to hear you back down
here are you gonna take the bet not how
bad you want your knees
either you in or you out all right
I'm trying to get more boy
I said Dan you said day and day I said
no sir are you in for your day I said no
like 10 minutes
all right okay I'm gonna tell you this
right now let's go yeah okay it's a
multiplayer game
it's gonna be on PS4 I would oh no I'm
just saying is there ever gonna be a cut
off
but I'm the most concerned about this is
we see Destiny having issues with the
Xbox One and PS4 thing again to me they
are they're going to cut that eventually
probably well I think Destiny three are
they're going to rebuild the game in
another engine but like to me they're
coming so like we're two years into this
gym and they're still gonna have that
that last that that factions on last gen
it's like I feel like they're gonna have
issues sooner rather than later yeah
that's the thing that's the thing too
it's like the the longer you wait the
quicker your game's probably going to
die in that sense where it's like okay
you let's say you wait until 2025 and
then you put out a game it's also on PS4
in a month that thing is unplayable you
know like if it's even playable in the
first place I I'm really convinced uh I
mean what do you what do you have
Hogwarts Legacy like just just got
delayed for delayed again delete again
because it's like you know why because
things don't work on those machines
anymore you're trying you're trying to
run Adobe Premiere on a on a TI-83 you
could tell Chris wanted to say different
sentence
here too so trust me
I'm gonna be honest like the the of the
of the multiplayer games that are coming
out of PlayStation right that we don't
really know about I think the only one
that isn't going to be cross gen is the
bungee whatever the Bungie's next thing
is I think you're right I I think yeah
yeah yeah that sounds about right
anything else anything else to me
they're getting that player base and
then to the point of the PC Day One
release yeah where you at a pure
multiplayer experience just pure
multiplayer you need a big uh Community
around it day one I would be
for The Last of Us factions is
when you look at the the press release
about what they talked about the game
seems like it is a lot more narratively
focused than just a straight up
multiplayer game I think that aspect is
going to be in there
but there it seems like it's going to be
a naughty dog narrative focused highly
polished
story based experience that you can play
with either one person or multiple
people and then you're gonna have the
verses part of it right the the PVP part
of it
um I just think that's not that so for
me day one on PC for that game no I
don't see it okay oh you don't see it oh
okay okay I don't see it right I see it
I see it 100 bro anything for anything
else coming down the pipeline way too
much
I'm the broken so Chris
he's trying to walk again
you think this game is coming out on PC
day one same time I think so it's a live
service well here's the thing there
would be no reason to delay it if it's a
live service game you know what I mean
like what do you what do you reading
I think you make it sound logic here
with that logic you won't bet your name
how many knees are you talking all right
we got two of them
I mean I I
um I need my knees for the fight I'll
give you one name
hold on so so slow-mo is saying that
they have stated oh that all all live
service games will be day one on PC okay
I'm done I'd like to see that quote slow
mo give me a link
is like I feel like delaying like if I
understand like the thought process of
like okay it will put out like I don't
know something like God of War on PS4
and then when God of War Ragnarok is out
we'll put it you know the original God
of War on PC to get the kind of people
in but with and I I do think you're
right that there is going to be some
narrative component to this version and
I maybe
I could see maybe they're doing they
them doing like a piecemeal type of
thing where like maybe there's narrative
content that's exclusive to the PS5 or
PS4 whatever and then yeah but but I do
think on PC generally like you're still
going to be able to participate in the
multi almost kind of like um destiny new
light in that right right in some way
yeah um where like if if they were going
to do that at all that's how they I
would see them doing it but I really do
think like in Live service I think the
the goal is to have the player base the
player base is as big as possible so
that no one's like spending ages in like
lobbies waiting for you know waiting for
cues and all this stuff
um
gotta interrupt one second shot the dip
down games gave me the link PlayStation
live service games coming to PC on day
one the head of PlayStation Studios
confirms that Sony will release live
service games on PC the same day as
consoles but not single player games so
it looks like Hermann Holst did make
this statement October 2022. yeah okay
so we gotta hold the feet
of Fire
are you
um
two knees at one time pause
so question question were all of these
games coming to PC yes all right now
we've confirmed do you think do you
think there's any one of them that they
would put uh free to play that's a
better question all of them
I feel like you don't do a game
about free to play Crazy that's a great
question
I think I I think that's the smart thing
however I do think Sony is arrogant
enough to charge
you know what they're like it's like
it's the last of us it's a premium
experience
I think being rare had this talk too I
think that's what I was I said I don't
want to commit because it makes sense
that it's supposed to be free to play as
live service but there's a part of me
that agrees with Chris that they look at
their cachet like this is a just like
that this is a premium experience and
and what they've showed with the remake
of the Remake and they even being
successful they have emboldened they
literally classify themselves in a whole
different category so that that's
there's a part of me that even though it
should be live service and free to play
that they could get away with it a
Gamers would be like well you don't know
dude I I really don't I don't I don't I
I see them being because here's also the
thing with Sony and Playstation in
general like every time that they have
offered anything free to play it's
usually been to mitigate the damage of
something that isn't great like there
was that do you remember that um
destruction or something yeah it was it
was like not Twisted Metal yeah they
were like yep where they were like this
is gonna be 70 bucks and everybody was
like yeah you think it's gonna be 70
bucks that's hilarious you think that
and then no one bought it and then they
were like ah it's free
and that's the Cadence that they've set
for free to play stuff and and I do
think that's going to change maybe it
maybe the last of us will be free to I
don't I really don't know but my
assumption is that they probably sell it
to you first I think they would try to
sell it to you or at the very least they
would be like hey
um do you have uh PS plus yeah like
maybe they'll do something like that
maybe maybe maybe
it comes day and date to PS plus
maybe that's maybe that's why yeah
whatever they're going to do in terms of
Ip with Last of Us let's say they they
re-re-re-make The Last of Us Part Two
and and then they're like if you buy The
Last of Us Part Two remake you get you
get the money yeah Last of Us Part Two
remake part one uh comes with the
multiplayer Perfections and then uh Last
of Us Part Two rebate part two uh remake
remastered
they split up the game
to give yo chill that's too much
what's faster last it was part two three
but look we gotta see how y'all jump in
real quick sorry okay did you get your
balls I'm sorry okay
I still support the PlayStation 4 to the
foreseeable future and it doesn't make
it you called this one for them not to
but the problem is everybody keeps
talking that you know Microsoft is
holding back this generation
and the series s is is the whole main
culprit little man is holding us back
the real little man is the PlayStation
4.
because the narrative is just Jaguar
cars B we talk
Jaguar cars holding us back Jaguar cars
is running Spider-Man and it's holding
back Saul's PC
right now could you imagine what the
fractions is gonna look like on your PC
it's it's it's I just you know what it
is it's like there's so many people who
are just okay with like yeah it runs at
12 frames per second but like it's fun
it looks like I I just can't I I can't
do it anymore yeah look I'll jump it
over too much to add but I'm kind of
with some I think that like I mean with
you at first Chris because it's part of
me from a tech standpoint you always
have that disappointment like damn you
want to see from a game design
standpoint you want to see this thing
pushed to the to the limit to see what
they want to see I want I want to see it
pull like something like dead space
where like dead space clear Dead Space
clearly like I I don't I I don't think
Dead Space could run on a PS4 in the in
the way that it does right the way that
it in the way that it runs you'd be
you'd be on those trams for 50 minutes
probably loading everything so and so I
just I want that like I want I want that
real like if if I'm going to play a Last
of Us thing at all right I would rather
it yeah not be held back by something
that is 10 times weaker than my current
busted up phone you know like hey that's
crazy no that's the thing and the thing
is from like I said from a pure selfish
text perspective I get it and and you
know it's naughty dog so you excited to
see what they can do graphically on you
know PS5 Hardware almost exclusively
obviously a PC
um to me though where I do kind of agree
with with King I mean excuse me from
solvers that
with live service I'm of a new mindset
in the sense that like I think to be
honest it doesn't even make sense to do
live service without cross-platform so
if you're going 100 you know what I'm
saying so if you're not even going to do
live service you know this is exclusive
to your ecosystem then the business
standpoint I understand and it's like
okay well we got these ps5s we still got
these PS4s we'll potentially but now put
this on PC and let's maximize this
ecosystems closed ecosystem for a live
service game as much as we can I do
understand the business logic of it you
know say the only thing that is
surprising is that the fact that we
thought they have you know say they kind
of resolved their supply chain issues
with PS5 so I thought at this point
maybe like you said like this is the
break-off now like okay we got consoles
out there we put this we drive people to
the new console new service that kind of
thing so I think that was a surprise but
I guess I guess when the development you
know took place PS4 probably was still
in play and that's it but um yeah I
thought I thought it was interesting to
see that this I guess I'm curious is one
how long does this continue what is the
cutoff date and then like we're going to
talk about Chris like are they going to
truly Go free to play with this title
because this title is very prestigious
to them that name there's an HBO series
we know naughty dogs catch shade so I'm
very curious if they feel they could
pull off that
not being free to play with this title
so that's all I got but yeah man thanks
uh my man ray gun for rocking as long as
he could appreciate you brother though
where can the fine people find you what
you got going on sir
oh man uh well I'm working on a bunch of
stuff but it's it's a lot of it's not
going to be done until after the fight
which is the fight's in a month yeah
that's uh you know you get uh they're
still create a classroom tickets
available I think it's uh www.the
creatorclash.com so you can get tickets
there it's a big charity event it's
gonna be really cool come watch me get
punched in the face Chris question
headgear right you're using headgear no
no oh damn oh damn I didn't know about
that boy there's no headgear are you
kidding let me ask you a question so you
turn pro no
no no no
the only reason why I asked because he
has to go to a commission he has to get
uh checked out by the doctor and all
that other yeah and he has to get the
paperwork so in the paperwork they asked
you a few amateur you Pro amateurs have
to wear headgear regardless to what
right so if you're going in without any
headgear then that means you have to
actually be classified as Pro well uh I
mean we're not doing the
I think I have like in a week or so in
like a week we're doing like a lot of
that stuff so I guess I if I assume
you're probably right then I guess we're
doing Pro then right but uh we're all um
you know it's it's everybody who's doing
it is basically at the same level we've
all been training for the same amount of
time none of us are like
like uh season
I'll put it this way I'm not going up
against somebody who's been boxing for
like 30 years okay you know what I mean
I'm going up against somebody else who's
done
um who's done pretty much the same
amount of training as I am uh and so
it's it's gonna be a an interesting
event last year's event was crazy and uh
it's it's a it's fun I I I did not
anticipate to like it as much as I do
yeah uh and so you know come come watch
it's gonna be is it the monumento thing
that you have that you are in control
opposed to other teams you know team
sports because this is technically a
team sport you have your corner man you
have your coach you have your stuff you
have people on the outside talking to
you and getting you through but
ultimately it's you yourself that's in
the ring and you have to overcome those
certain things does that combat that
that mono e mono is that your driving
force that that feel because you keep
saying getting punched in the face and
punching the face is probably not gonna
happen if you know you move your head
properly but yeah yeah so like is well I
think for me it's just the the the the
like tuning into the Instinct that's
there that like you don't really like
think about if you're not really in a in
a fight yeah um and so you know I my
coach has been has been boxing for like
30 like 35 years so when we spot and we
Spar constantly and he's really really
good and then so when I spar with other
people who are you know who are around
my level it feels ridiculous like I feel
like I feel like I have to cheat code I
feel like I've almost like been over
preparing and like yeah of course like
boxing is dangerous it's not like a joke
um nobody nobody's going in there
treating it like a like a like a meme or
like you know not seriously
um everybody's working really hard we
know the risks obviously people like
there's probably gonna be people with
concussions obviously it's boxing it's
like my coach says um you know uh right
yeah people on the people in the chat
like acting like I haven't been punched
is it hilarious
you're fighting a dude named Froggy
Fresh right Fresh Froggy Fresh salute to
you brother again always a pleasure to
work with you LSA fam in the building
you already know addict let's give a
little outro get outro for uh for Chris
before you go
yeah what's funny is the first time I
came across you was on a defining Duke
uh when ACG was part of the podcast and
I didn't they I got like in the middle
of it when I first started I was like
who is this dude because I'm sitting
here talking or calling I'm like I want
this dude on the podcast this is what
the that's on uh defining dude and he's
like he's like yeah that's that Chris
dude it was uh I think you were talking
about Halo or something probably I
probably was yeah yeah most likely I was
like I like the vibe man we got to get
him on the show man of course man so
it's fun for Reagan before he do this
yeah I'm Chris I'm you know I've been
listening to taker symbols from the
beginning so just that that dynamic
between you and Colin I love because I
just I love sort of snarky sarcastic
humor like like two guys who like lean
into the hole we hate the whole world
type of humor and I mean the dynamic
between you two and now we're dust with
uh with Dustin is is hilarious so a
little funny anecdote was for me I was
like excited like you have a Puerto
Rican guy on the show or whatever
mine is in there right I don't know if
you remember this episode but this is
something happened I was like oh I said
I gotta I gotta revoke the plantain card
from Chris
Rice
what happened it was it was the mucho
gusto episode
so I was listening to it and the guy
wrote in very very excited to write it
he was like Chris you know I don't know
if he was Puerto Rican or whatever mucho
gusto right and Chris is like what the f
is that Chris
what is that it literally translate to
much like or a lot like what is that
that's a stand and I'm listening I'm
like you're reading of most Latinos what
what is wrong with this guy I got tight
because I was at first I thought
Christian's giving him the ribbon right
but he you he even Colin jumped in like
yeah it doesn't make any sense
ripping him a new one yeah
he's like he never wrote in again
I love that
that was that was so hilarious
honestly man like I love what you do I
love that Dynamic I love everything else
you're doing uh this boxing thing it
takes a lot to be like hey I'm gonna
jump in the room and learn how to do
this and uh so congrats to you man good
luck with that keep your head on the
swivel I mean I'm I'm I think it's gonna
think people are going to be surprised
it's it's going to be a fun like it's
gonna be it's gonna be a cool show
whatever I don't know what the [__] I
don't know how it's gonna go because I
you know it's it's fighting it can
happen but uh everybody's taking it
super super seriously it's uh
everybody's really into it uh I have a
lot of respect for it in a way that I
didn't before because I just wasn't
really paying attention to it but uh you
know it's it's crazy I got I gotta
tomorrow I'm training I think twice oh
wow so it's starting to ramp up so no
doubt kid yeah Fairway boss to to Chris
before you go yeah okay so
um I didn't really know what to expect
today and you know so you sit down and
you just you know let it come to you and
the interview actually turned out way
better than I expected to be honest with
you didn't have any expectations yeah no
confidence in Chris today
I had no expectations no expectations
when you don't know somebody you don't
have any experience 100 yeah
I loved the fact that you know that he's
willing to do all these different things
try everything and do it fearlessly I
mean listen
um one to train the box is one thing you
know to to to put on the mitts and stuff
like that is it's is another thing to
know that you're actively going to fight
yeah
that's a different Beast Within itself
right because you have to come through a
resolutions in your mind that you know
I'm going into fight I'm going to
actually engage in somebody that's
willing to hurt me and I'm willing to
harm them but at the same time this is a
game so you have to wrap your mind
around that I'm not willing to injure
this person I'm just willing to beat
this person so right that that mindset
is incredible right so in order to have
that and every time you step under that
rope and you go into that rope you turn
to a whole different Beast you're in a
vulnerable Unstoppable Beast once you
step into that ring and you will over
conquer anybody that's on the other side
that's fantastic I love that mindset I
appreciate that man the bigger thing
that I'm because see I don't did the
boxing thing yeah he do that
that comedy
the level of balls it takes to stand up
naked in front of everybody else because
you're naked up there yeah they see
right through in your in your mind you
they see through you
and you're there to make them laugh to
Comedy is very subjective so you're a
very open book dude from one Dynamic to
the next I take my hat off to you it's
fantastic and you're in your Prime
you're young in your Prime doing these
things so it's nothing but greatness
gonna come from it man I I mean I mean
that's a lot I appreciate that very much
it might be like the actually nicest
thing I've heard in years oh but uh
brother I want I want to see the boxing
I wanna I wanna hit a comedy I'm I'm
really intrigued by Chris Reagan now
like I'm a Chris Reagan fan now hello I
want to see these things all right
because you know I want to support you
in your courageousness going forward
yeah
well hopefully hopefully after the after
the match I'll get back to uh because my
schedule has been ruined by this because
it's just like it's it's it's because
it's not only training it's it's like
everything shifts it's like the schedule
shifts your diet shifts yeah everything
and then because your diet shifts your
mood shift it's all it's a whole bunch
of things the discipline that it
requires to to even prepare for
something like this is insane it's
something that I want to prove to myself
too that I could like do and uh I'm kind
of you know the fact I've been doing it
for like that's about eight nine months
something like that so it's you know
processed up but in that ring you
already got it and make sure call is
probably going with the LSM Trunks and
you're doing the request so what are we
doing you get the big tattoo on his back
yeah
you're doing the parikha gloves or the
trunks what we doing you gotta wrap for
PR what's up
I got bigger ones obviously soft do we
approve guys
we gotta we gotta talk to our boy Tito
Trinidad
nah he need Pepe from the Bronx
[Laughter]
enjoy your day brother the absolute
pleasure of my lsf fam Chris Ray Gun the
man
always a pleasure brother yeah thank you
guys so much for having me I'd love to
come on again yeah
right after the fight yeah
take care guys peace likewise bro peace
peace hold on let me go back let me see
oh we got a bunch okay
we're starting out with let's play with
each other's Giants
from
you remember when he mispronounced
oh he's taking his earrings off
everything he said
yeah that's right that's right that's
right oh this way
he saw that I can't wait to read that
one he took his earrings off and was
like no you're not coming from my man
you're gonna hear song say thank you
boo-boo
I
hope you got uh
um
[Laughter]
yeah VPN so so you know he can't find
out where you where you work the network
GPS
nobody better disrespect has been that's
it let that be known then we have Mark
bajeel I think I I think I got that
right hopefully
six Euro Super Chat how can I get that
valari pillow in the Netherlands I only
see the options for us UK and Canada oh
nevertheless okay
you buy the pillow send it to your
friend in America and then he sell it to
you
this is what you do at did you do on
Twitter at
ironlordpodcastlary which is today let's
get their official Twitter account the
valari right and then just say hey I'm
in the um the Netherlands I really want
it and we will we will work this out
brother yeah we'll get that rocket no
doubt so yeah on Twitter it was at the
Volare I just want to make sure so yes
at the Volare and then also at iron law
podcast say who you are on Twitter yeah
we got you and we go we go expedite you
mean this Ferrari pillow
I like her attic rubber they like that
yeah
excuse me
I got that face now I ain't feeling
y'all gotta take the camera
that's what he was hiding under that
trench yeah
Kelly two dollar Super Chat hang it
ain't looking good for Microsoft
looking worse for you and your
PlayStation 4.
stop holding me back girls
shout out to Kelsey there we go Robert
Kelly Two Dollars to protect that smelly
rat Ryan sabotaging Todd's joint
pill away
for two years five dollars stupid chat I
know I'm late to the party I saw that
Guardians of the Galaxy is leaving
decided to play it that game is
phenomenal I'm all channeled I'm on
chapter 10. love it
on I own that that's it we pulled the
Starfield or the pillow he still waiting
okay it's coming it's coming it's coming
at 60 frames
it's gonna be better when you get it
you just wait six more minutes uh one
thing I'll say is quality's worth the
waiters
hey at least we didn't give expectations
like Microsoft yeah we see the next 12
bucks
you could have got it in a week but you
had to sew the patches on yourself you
know it's funny when you buy any think
from us in terms of clothing teeth bring
you away oh my God
I'm gonna start it with our good friends
all right
remember for 24 months Lord Bronx good
looking what's going on brother I'm 100
with kids
they riding gangster list I'll see you
that we have tip twelve five dollars to
love that name two well five dollars did
I miss the king this tape or was it
delayed like starfish
he's gonna get that work they thought I
was gonna be nice sorry yeah you gotta
look the king's timeline on Twitter it's
there
uh then we have hargit to knee remember
for one year five dollar Super Chat
Chris has it right all release dates are
lies to begin with don't expect anyone
to make the release date sadly the norm
now it really is because you're accepted
you ain't gonna accept it with your Uber
Eats next time Uber Eats late don't give
them a one star give him that five star
like you give Sony fantastic it was
worth the wait
remember keep the energy don't play
don't play don't play how much you want
to sign out
and the flight tell you uh we're gonna
have a layover over in uh Japan what we
need y'all to do is just sit tight don't
be upset don't have a layover in Japan I
want you to cross your fingers and stay
on the runway
and be like this is
not what it was promised to you
thank you sir next time say something
please
and we have Mandingo mcstickins once
again remember for two years five dollar
super chat if it bleeds we can kill it
this king's fractured prediction
let's stop real continue to cook no
issues on the delay more damage is done
by a buggy game versus
you know what I realized now we're
definitely gonna see kiosks's at E3 on
uh on on Starfield they ain't gonna be
they're not gonna be on the uh E3
let me know I'm talking about the
Microsoft thing
there's definitely going to be your
kiosk gameplay demos there you think for
like a RPG is dead
yeah there's no way in September it's
it's it's not at that event like yeah
that's hard to believe because you craft
that whole thing around Starfield this
is the banana in the tail that's my fear
that's my biggest fear is that they
craft this June event around Starfield
and don't have nothing to show right
that's what I'll be 100 with you King
100 with you that'd be tight with that
I'm gonna tell y'all I'm gonna tell
y'all y'all ain't gonna like me this
yeah
I'm trying to pull a Flim Flam giving us
all last year crap this year and holding
this year's stuff for next year just I
hope not man I need to punch you in your
mouth I really am I hope not but I am
concerned
to go and punch you in your face because
y'all seem to be suckers oh so I want
Spider-Man to come because I'm hearing
rumors Spider-Man talk about we
September too so if Spider-Man come out
in September 2 and just run a run up
your backside I'll serve you right it
served you right duck in the fade it
serves you right not doing your stuff in
June you know Spider-Man run up your
backside in September Spider-Man gonna
be a huge competitor too it's gonna be
blood in your snow because I'ma tell you
this I know who gonna rate higher right
off the rip so yeah keep on running from
these fights
you guys are trying to put it out
Paul let me ask you a question
Sony comes out and says September what
is it the sixth yeah yeah Spider-Man two
to what do you think Microsoft you can't
move now
look like I'm not saying there's no way
that they can compete with Spider-Man
but you don't want to compete with
Spider-Man like how long you gonna delay
this ice cream from getting to your
house
that game is ready in PlayStation like
we're gonna drop that Spiderman I had
the most premium premium milk I'm like
uh I don't know man part of me is like
uh you know dude oh that's nice if it's
a daddy Metacritic I remember all this I
got all let me see
ladies
I'm not talking about Starfield I'm
talking about competing with an iconic I
understand
why are people surprised stop yo kept
showing music Snippets no gameplay it's
like not saying he's dropping but only
filming his equipment
there we have Robert Kelly
little Timmy's Final hours damn
how messy messy how messy then we got
slow mo back slap member for two years
two dollars for chatter rest in peace
little Timmy who died before star fuel
came out yeah this fictional story is
hilarious what to me man on his casket
he said to the Moon
they uh they put on like the back of the
Starfield boxing members
he said how many times
how many times is argument going to the
circle oh yeah it's been all day it's
all day we knew this was coming I'm
documenting it all don't worry about it
[Music]
again once again kept saying that Todd
is the king of cat nobody listened damn
never mind
it's just crazy how many of you are
willing to have that game come out yeah
there's nothing from Halo Infinity
gave us a funny bro you're hilarious
hilarious babies
you care about the list Wars more than
you care about the game yeah but he
tried Todd is a gunslinger baby and we
so happy we dropped out early
spaghetti well he ain't had nothing to
do with that just like you said Okay
Okay so this game's busted cause you've
made him rushing out he's gonna have
something to do oh well listen obviously
Todd listen to Clark
obviously listen obviously the Kool-Aid
one so
until I see him come for me no the list
did not it all right they wouldn't have
got to smoke a day to listen to the list
they want to hold ties back y'all only
time
and I think we had a talk with our
brother I think he he's very compromised
and upset after the beating the physical
meeting of Todd the guard how he tried
to stroll off God Howard talking about
and it didn't go down this time
and I think that's the beginning
those two pictures the picture of me
talking to Todd I think that's it in the
picture a song with [__] I'm talk
y'all could have known right there that
he wasn't gonna make his release date
with me he got the face like he'd been
called to the office
that Kingston next to toddy that you
could see the urine coming down no I
don't do it like that he was really nice
he was really nice it was nice he was
like who are y'all like yeah
absolutely terrified
the situation
[Music]
Phil was in the background like Todd
stay strong
at the time that was a funny night it
was a funny night continue that was
hilarious and we had let me see clutch
man ten dollars which have Microsoft is
in a difficult position half the fan
base says don't show games outside the
next E3 the others say we want to get
excited about the future show it's a two
to three year road map who do you listen
to It's hard cause when you don't you
need to do both though just you could
show the games just don't put definitive
dates on stuff no this is the thing
right they they just they haven't hit a
Cadence correct okay to be able to show
like where they're at the point where
they haven't talked about a game it's
six months out and they're sure of that
and they could show it right they
haven't been like that we got to be
honest too a lot of this is is
every time they people don't act like
Mike uh they don't act like PlayStation
and uh Nintendo delay stuff because yeah
when their games come out people are
okay you know I trust them I trust them
because of the track record that they
have yeah but when you have the track
record that's up and down like Mike I
saw people aren't willing to give them
that's the benefit of the Xbox they lost
the generation they weren't supposed to
lose the Xbox one generation technically
right because they came into the
quote-unquote favorite people thought
they after the 360 they the at least the
third parties at least we we know that
for sure and then the fact that they
bungle that generation now they're in
this position where it's like it does
like they're not afforded what everybody
else is afforded and people will say
it's unfair and it may be unfair but
until they continue this Cadence like
now that it seems to be this year once
they get on that all that will stop but
that's why I said if games gotta be good
because if the games are good you stop
to talk
what ended up happening is that they're
able to like you know Starfield comes
out success Fable comes out success you
know a valid comes out success hellblade
then you're not gonna hear people say so
let me tell y'all something and this is
real talk for I know King is upset but
if Starfield is that game and we talking
Elder Scrolls type energy the duels have
made Oblivion and Skyrim and they are a
nominee just being enough forget winning
being a nominee for the game when's the
last time we had an XBox exclusive on
any stage I think the outer worlds
exactly that's what it's about so when
you get that you start you start the
Chain Reaction the here come potential
hellblade here come potential foul did
it you take all that talking out because
now you've established quality they've
already started with high five Rush let
them cook and imagine if they Rush
Starfield and they and they lost their
opportunity I don't like that face
it's true like in the year in the year
when high five Rush could be out up
there as well because I'm gonna tell you
right now if we got freaking the cat
game last year Hi-Fi Rush needs to be
there bro
you can have a dominator high five Rush
it's stuff you'll do with Starfield
doing let's just say hellblade come out
and do what they do you got three in the
mix I mean four is it gonna do what it
does in its categories
yeah but not Game of the Year boys that
ain't doing the game but we know that's
the de facto racing Sports whatever yeah
it will be the Races
they just gotta show up
that's no question so that's all I'm
saying stop it so bad he is so
devastated buddy no no you know what's
crazy I don't really care about the gay
boys
you should have never said it no no no
you're right you want to know you know
I'm dead with you on that you know they
should have never said
I agree
I feel like I feel like that's a large
so then all you show was 20 games last
year you're right let's keep it above
you're right you stole 20 games the 10
most important games are not out Hollow
Knight Flint um Flintlock this other
game
um replace not out yet uh star field
Forza come on
impressive game the question the
question King what we need to ask is why
did they feel the need to do that that's
the real question right to you I know
because they had nothing lasting
yes yes
but the six months you didn't get you
got just washed that it's that's so
weird to me like that's why I said it
feels like it has to be like a business
consideration or something because it's
just weird to constantly promise things
that you know you're gonna have to roll
back up right the only thing I could
think of it we got to be let's be real
about the business
you can't say that in a that defected
positively the business of them trying
to go grow game pass with Starfield and
redfall dude that does not make it in
2022. so maybe the money people are like
yo we gotta give them something on the
road map to stay in the joint and maybe
it's all it is yeah it's locking in Game
Pass subscribers right to believing that
your service is going to have these 30
games for this year it didn't right so
now let's say the person that paid that
break no I feel that 12 months I'm all
in this is what you said all right well
that's the commitment to the consumer
right all right now you're gonna say yo
but we did drop high five Rush that
wasn't shown there right and we didn't
have a couple of other games that we put
there that wasn't shown in there so
that's your satiate you okay that aside
two three games you put in there where's
the other seven games tracks what's the
most graphical where where is the
showpiece where's the show running
thanks you gave me a bunch of rice and
beans where the hell is the meat sauce
and what now it puts undue pressure on
themselves for the gigs to be good
because not everybody's all ready
now we've got to come out in September
oh it gotta be a
my thing is here let it getting cook
you're stupid behind shouldn't have said
that facts you should have said yo these
games we have these games coming out
within the next two years yeah um this
is what we're looking at this is what
you can look forward to playing but no
what you did was it was a marketing
tactic to hold a fool in place this is
why I said how do you keep a fool in
suspense me just sitting here in
suspense expecting these games to drop
oh we're gonna get a release date oh
March we should have a a
um a live uh show oh no it's June now
June show was looking kind of iffy now
E3 is wrapped around this thing and then
now it's gonna be less game showed what
if what it what what if all right
no but but here's the thing though we
can't act like there's not a troll
there's we can't act for us but we can't
act like 2021 and it happened let's just
be clear 2021 they happen where they
actually had a monster Cadence of the
games when they released on time
Psychonauts published out a year the
metacrite so they showed the same time
and my throat was very dry as parked
yeah yeah
but but my thing is there is an
immediate history of it we've seen it
Psychonauts Halo Forza Horizon
but you can't take that away like it
don't exist that's the thing
prisoners of the moment a little bit
guys
when it comes to that particular issue
is
we can definitely give them the
satisfaction of 2021 yes but they've had
way more misses on years than than hits
oh for sure and it's like one of those
things where it's like as much as I want
to give them 20 21 100 at the same time
it's like but you've only really done
that one time in a long time I respect
that 2022 was was really lacking I
didn't feel like uh you know 2020 wasn't
that good you know they they'd be
missing a lot more than they hit and you
know we keep saying stuff like you know
we got to give them more more time to
get these and what they do they have to
get these games out but it's like I
think the biggest issue when it came to
that whole you know 12-month thing is if
it would have been one game that would
have been different you know Starfield
got pushed back it's a double win scores
is not there you know King says you know
Flintlock and stuff's not there it's
that messaging
Microsoft has is that messaging like I
agree why would you come out there and
just say bold statements like you're
gonna play these games until and guess
what the first first thing that I saw
the moment that that delayed was
announced was videos of Sarah Bono on
screen says these games are coming out
in the next absolutely they did
themselves no favor all I'm saying is
Gamers we gotta we right to be upset and
hold their feet to the fire to be
accountable but also Gamers and that's
why I'm being messy if these games are
fire after all this smoke people gonna
forget all that so I remember nobody
remembers the release date bro Remember
When Brad Miller yo when it's gonna come
out
and that's the thing
the thing if the choice is fire is just
they put pressure on himself unduly this
is about me being consistent I respect
it right you know first you got to have
some Integrity with something right yeah
if if you're gonna hold an eye Rose
PlayStation all the time they get to
work all the time you know and and
rightfully so because they're always
doing something bungling but I'm not
gonna look over at the one that you know
your favorite kid that is bungling as
well and and this is of his own volition
nobody forced that on you yeah you did
this to yourself so to say that this
hasn't been done in the industry and the
you know the 12-month thing and okay
and yeah you you fix them rights and
you're right and Wrongs that was
overhead that you was doing at three
four three
and everybody keeps pointing at Halo
everybody keeps pointing oh y'all don't
want another Halo situation oh y'all
don't want another Halo situation that
was an isolated incident
but but I say this Chris Chris ray gun
and you guys have no Master Chief
Collection yeah y'all said it yes you're
right you know how you're gonna treat
your main franchise that's supposed to
be one of the pillars that holds
everything up and everything right your
name is basically Halo
How You Gonna treat that with the
disrespect that you have you know in all
these years so you know I hear you I
hear you guys my rent has only been the
12 thing yeah and I think I think
honestly it's just going to take these
games to be great for you to get your
confidence back on what they say and
then for them to actually not talk when
they don't need to talk about dates you
know what I'm saying and just put things
out so that you don't you don't have
those situations again hopefully this is
a teaching moment for them because they
cannot continue where I'm with you is
they cannot continue to do that right
because then it's like your word be
absolutely nothing but anyway we go on
super long success yeah I just remember
back in the day when we never knew when
the game was coming remember that you
had to call the game store every day
yo figure it's all face like yo you
ain't read about 100 Super Chat yeah we
got you face we got you yeah yeah it's
coming it's coming for sure
and we got tipped well two dollar super
chat if Timmy could he'd retire before
Eldridge
that was hilarious then we got Nintendo
on the otaku remember for one year five
dollars for chat it was a lose-lose if
they didn't do the 12 month they would
get roasted again for no dates at least
there was a chance of a win by doing it
yeah but then the backlash if they do it
like it's you know whatever I get it
lose lose you're right we got base 23b
can why two dollar Super Chat Spider-Man
2 and Starfield head to head this year
could very well be although I I see
Spider-Man later I don't see September
but we'll see we'll see that'd be crazy
then we have my name is mud 50 super 10
yeah
yo fifty dollar super Jack King you are
comedy gold thank you iron Lords for
providing the best gaming podcast on the
web shame on them for killing Timmy
we should get a little Timmy trending
man yeah he did his thing today then we
got robbed the Don 202 10 super chat
everyone is entitled to be mad but I
knew I I knew understood why anyone
would I never knew I never understood
why anyone would trust a multi-trillion
billion dollar company that's like
trusting any fast food joint is serving
you real beef potato slash french fries
yeah
it's food that's all it's sustenance
Carl Andrews Junior two dollars of
attack King is 100 right Xbox needs to
do better yes
absolutely absolutely
Spartan goes 17 two pound Super Chat
better start calling him sir cap a lot
wow
there we go Phase 23 weekend 100 stupid
chat shout out to you thank you brother
appreciate it absolute salute sir I give
King props for calling out Xbox
PlayStation fans don't worry about
delays because PlayStation pipeline is
on point
every game that you literally got has
had some form of delay the only thing is
y'all got they don't tell y'all anything
so yo y'all don't even have shows
no these are the only guys that stick
into a format that's actually being out
there so yeah you don't have to worry
about it because you'll get it when they
service you know what's funny King if
you really think about them we always
wonder you know why do a lot of like
PlayStation content send around Xbox
content because they kind of not a lot
of talk about it
oh that we have we have tipped whale two
dollars of attacks so Xbox has lies and
Playstation has stitches
I thought Jay dub and uh and Timmy just
fell apart
don't do that yeah I got you baby
you still sure about Spider-Man 2 PS5
only yes
when I get your knees
and listen when you send them back I
want Lubriderm
[Laughter]
that's fine that's fair that's a fair
that's fair
you know we should locate
once things are settling down when you
win like when you win I bid the knees of
it you get like one of those small
little trophies to put something [__]
have to disagree with the take on
factions on PS4 you need a player base
in games like fortnite are still on last
gen God is coming to switch you gotta
remember that yes yeah that's coming to
switch in a different manner
Wi-Fi only okay there we go so we said
Wi-Fi only slow mo back slap member for
two years five dollars Super Chat y'all
confirm y'all confirmed it already but I
sent Cog another link can I want your
left ACL your right MCL and happy
kneecap slow mo was ready he was ready
slow mo slow mo slow mo don't do it to
yourself you don't bet on the division
bro
we already know that yo yo yo
your decision making is kind of impaired
I think you got a couple of concussions
about the division slander
he put a lot of he put a lot of cards in
that uh that third person uh multiplayer
game him BG loved that game what was
that game called
um did they do that I remember that this
weekend it was a fun game though it was
a fun game what division two had the new
raid this weekend
he go extra hard on him continue you
know what's funny someone I remember
someone saying on the last word in a
Super Chat that more people know about
uh Call of Duty's raid than they know
about the divisions right damn
exotic
yeah
continue on then we have J1 member for
two what's my bronze greetings Lord
Starfield trailer gave me Interstellar
and the expanse Vibes can't wait for BDS
to be back great show and great guests
I really liked it you gave me hurry up
and wait Bob
then we have Chris McComb with the two
pounds for chat have you guys tried psvr
too what are your thoughts on it I
haven't even I haven't had a chance to
play since the additional week I haven't
played we did a podcast on it too didn't
we yeah yeah
um yeah so we definitely was last week
or something before what about yourself
if you want detailed uh things you
should probably go back to those uh
podcasts yeah the car go back I think I
said he liked it though yeah I think we
both like it
what are you talking about talking about
the psvr too
car can't even paying attention
I'm acting up on Twitter
thoughts on psvr two College oh about
four sorry um Horizon calls it about
love it just it's very crab heavy but I
actually love it a lot of just just one
energy and um what you call it uh demio
and uh the other one the um no man's sky
is amazing I love that West guy yeah
crazy yeah yeah if funny Chris talked
about in Shadow of the Colossus I would
love to see that in New York
that would be one of I don't know I feel
like that would give me a headache
I think I literally might play that game
and die
there we have a Dragonheart and you'll
be ten dollars
made a big fan at one of the events with
the tattoo that says
lmpwyj Lawrence will say what does that
mean and the fan will look over the
South's Direction with the soonest the
evil smile damn my man
he always has to come with these
scenarios
don't put that in people's head man yeah
they gonna show up
hey King I'm like he right over there
he's right over there
he's
gonna pull up on King he'll be like you
know what I have to see you guys yeah
[Laughter]
ubereats
Etc even if they are late don't mess
with the folks making or delivering your
food exactly
shut up I mean
shut up got your food already they don't
know you're gonna hit them again
shut up time time
your food came in late and cold and you
talk about but I'm still gonna get
before star shut up be a disrespect for
the people that's making your food yeah
okay you got robbed the dog 202 2000
stop it y'all said stop it y'all
Spider-Man not even on PC day one
um
yeah we have Hardy today again
Spider-Man whatever Xbox will have the
biggest game of the year Call of Duty
Call of Duty is bigger than any Sony
game just ask Jim right oh damn yeah
yeah I feel you on that but I think
we're mainly talking about like an
exclusive Factor because Call of Duty's
gonna sell all the exclusives it does
every year on everything but as far as
like a value on a specific platform I
think that's why Spider-Man's being
compared to Starfield in this particular
podcast the first part versus first
party yeah
yeah we have heart beats in the again
five dollars Super Chat wait we're not
about to forget that Xbox had two games
nominated for Game of the Year in 2021
tgas oh yeah oh yeah yeah they had the
highest metal of any Publishers
no nobody forgets we just remember 2022.
what Gamers
we say it all the time it's what you've
done for me for sure for sure all that
good work was out the window then we
have a hiking City again oh they're
consistent consistently delayed thank
you
hmm
I sat back and all for watching that I
was like wow they sent out there to be
oh God
I said you know what because when it
when it comes back it's gonna be like oh
you know Sarah Bond said it was going to
be the 12 months I'm watching it I'm
just a conspiracy theory
I'm really focused I'm looking at you
guys sideways bro I'm really looking at
you sideways I love the hell out of you
but I'm gonna tell you I'm starting to
believe everything is Sovereign
Timmy's already a dust pile he died
waiting for the Last of Us factions
multiplayer no that's that was that was
clone version three
little Tibby's die every day
came out couple see you got a chance to
play and um actually what's up let's
finish with that one that's that I want
to finish with that last yeah all right
so so you start off EXO Primal and the
extra primal thing it's just funny to me
and this this is it uh with Capcom had
their uh sort of little like event where
it kind of showcasing you know stuff
that's up I'm coming they show more
resident before uh what do they call it
officially the spotlight just yeah so
they talked a little bit more about Mega
Man Battle Network they have another
commentator coming to uh uh Street
Fighter six
um just a bunch of little the Ghost
Trick random detective that they were
talking about
um on during the switch stream stuff
like that so out of that they talked
about exoprimo finally and the thing
about EXO Primal is that it is coming
day one to Game Pass and what's
interesting about that is that this
would be the first Capcom game ever to
come day one to Game Pass and to me I
see it as okay it's fantastic you know I
I always thought it felt like a weird
kind of game but I want to see what it
is but it kind of feels like a
conversation was had about the
availability of a certain fighting game
that was exclusive to PS5 and it feels
like EXO Primal is the consolation prize
for that because again back then
Capcom was a very different Capcom than
that back then they were on the ropes
when that Street Fighter 5 PlayStation
deal was made this is a different Capcom
the conversation is different the bag
has to be different but I really do feel
that shout out to Phil I think the
conversation was had wow hey what up
with that sf6 you're like nope can't
really do that though you know it's
gonna be everywhere I think it's gonna
be a big thing take EXO Primal but the
conversations are happening with Capcom
hello but you could think how many years
we've had Game Pass since the first time
we see a Capcom game day one and it is
very very interesting and I think you
know when we start talking about delays
of games and stuff like that I think the
work is being done to fill in gaps where
they see them arising so this is cool I
hope XO Prime was good I hope we don't
fall into the damn conversation about
you know Game Pass mediocrity I don't
want to hand you all about that we don't
want to what is it an extraction
situation Rainbow Six
I find this very interesting I wonder if
you guys agree with me or I got the 10-4
hat on I mean I'll jump in at it starts
ready
yeah I mean when it comes down to it
right it's not a particular game that is
excites me actually got invited to like
a content creator thing with it oh
um but it's one of those things that's
like I hope people enjoy it I do think
it does give a diverse kind of lineup
that isn't necessarily in Game Pass
currently at the moment and you know
when it comes to these types of like I
don't know I don't know if it's a games
of service entirely it looks like one uh
but when it comes to these type of games
to me you never know when these things
are going to hit when they're not going
to hit yeah and you know
I don't blame Microsoft for going out of
their way to get this particular game
and it gives me hope of Capcom too where
you know maybe uh that Mega Man game
will come eventually not necessarily you
know to Gamepad uh to Game Pass but just
the platform in general like the more I
see these games going in Game Pass the
more I feel like okay maybe the
relationship's getting better to where
those games will start missing the
platform in general
yeah okay your thoughts on the uh Capcom
situation XO Primal any relations
well
you know they probably had conversations
about the street fighter you know
situation and exoprano this is a new IP
they're not too sure what it's going to
do in a while they probably offered it
to PlayStation PlayStation was like no
hard pass and Microsoft was like of
course you know we'll take it over here
and Game Pass give you some upfront
money Sony didn't care for The Upfront
money because they don't know what the
IP is going to do it doesn't have a
track record Microsoft is willing to
take that gamble on these things uh Sony
has that 5 billion in acquisition money
but they looking to AC acquire stuff
then they're not probably trying to
invest inside their services they have
IPS that's going to hit their services
that's going to uh generate Revenue in
their services so I don't think they
looked at it as a viable option
Microsoft did because again they know
their delays and the games that are
supposed to be out so here we goes with
these Bride made games that are popping
up you know that we that they're taking
a fly on Microsoft figures
if they take flyers on all these new IPS
these third-party IPS and one of them
actually hits they can keep it in there
for a while and it can actually generate
Revenue so they're willing to bankroll
stuff and bet that it'll happen in this
way you know Capcom this is a win-win
they're going to get the engagement from
Game Pass automatically off the rip you
got 30 plus million people that's going
to engage with your game if you have one
percent of those people purchase that
game that's three million right
purchasing that game only on that
platform and then whatever it sells on
the PlayStation platform and then at
some point in time it'll go into PS uh
plus and they're going to generate
Revenue so it's a Capcom is doing smart
business as a third party uh developer
going and seeking options for new IPS
off but Microsoft it's it's a lesson
learned with against an impact right
yeah yes
no you're absolutely right I mean I'm
sorry I'm gonna I was gonna say and then
you look at something like outriders yep
yep you can make an argument that that
game wouldn't have been nowhere near as
successful
and I think that's I think about
yourself smart for making it I actually
love this because one
you know surprising too it's surprising
and the Capcom relationship to me what
my Xbox has always been shaky you know I
never understood I mean look I get it
but people I think what's more egregious
than even the Final Fantasy 7 remake
excuse for the record contest had
problem with exclusive content come on
but I have to say I thought it was more
egregious what Street Fighter 5 being
exclusive to PlayStation 4. but you got
to remember at that period of time they
went to Microsoft and asked Microsoft to
bankroll them Sony gave him the bag hey
and if that's the case fine but I just
felt it was unacceptable any reason that
one of the Premier Strat fighting games
are not is not on the Xbox right yeah
because it was everywhere but but I give
you the money if you call if you come to
me and tell me yo I don't have the money
to do XY and you run the project I gotta
find the project I get it and I get I
get the rights I get that it just to
meet with the relationship with Capcom
just wasn't strong to me yeah it just
felt all around and then like monster
hunter game and stuff like that now
we're starting to see some of that kind
of slipping the game pass you know and
yes make no mistake there is this is the
start of the relationship this is
something EXO Primal first of all I like
the way it looked I think gravity look
phenomenal like I just want to see how
it plays I like the whole idea of an
online kind of like a Dino Crisis Co-op
type situation so it's speaking to me
personally and then the cinematics
what's up
was Phil in charge at the time
in in the current position that he's in
when the street fighter deal went
through not the head of Microsoft gaming
he was probably he wasn't right not at
them now he was not at the table at that
point he would became he was President
he was still under people yeah uh that
had issue right so so then it's easy to
say that after he became uh oh yeah
he started getting these capcoms he
started building you see the capcoms the
atlases you see it like that's why I
kept telling me people kept laughing and
saying oh they're in Japan they're not
going to do anything I'm seeing the
fruits of the labor you're starting to
see where and then so I was going to
talk about guilty gears drive and you
know I'm saying so to me yes is it main
vane capcom's right no but like addict
said this if this could be could
potentially be an um outrider situation
where it's a new IP you're unsure of it
has a multiplayer component as an online
component if it hits and you on Game
Pass what was the talk at the time
outriders came out and I started to pop
yo it's free over there on Game Pass now
you get all all this engagement right
you're starting to see the depending
you're starting to see the East ease up
even with war long yo new IP they the
key with Game Pass to make it more
attractive we know the first party stuff
I got you at one second is that to me
third party day in day is what really
gets it to cook to me because you get
someone to say okay why am I going to
get another 70 version of this where I
can get it in this service you gotta
addict and I'll finish and I was gonna
say you know
listen he send it to me telepathically
I'm just regurgitating no like I said
we'll see I mean I I like the idea of it
we'll see if it's actually good you know
but if it does if it is good it's a
great it's probably low risk for Capcom
and then maybe that relationship gets
better and you start to improve it but
that's gonna say so if he's gonna do the
uh but they're gonna we're gonna do
Resident Evil what are we doing
uh what other thing you want to talk
about it
um yeah no no I like I said before I was
playing strive and again back to the
fighting game thing you know Game Pass
you're not traditionally getting a lot
of those games right these get Arc
system works games that are launching
kind of like an on Playstation you have
them on Playstation maybe PC day and
date the fact that they come in a Game
Pass yes better late than never
um strive has not hit uh PS plus though
so this is that's important that's
important to to point out that they're
working to get this game on this
platform get it in front of a bunch of
eyes anybody who whether you like
fighting games or not you throw that
game on that's the thing you look at you
turn you'll be like Mom look look at
this it is it's a cartoon
for you yeah the thing I was gonna say
is like uh you I don't think wulong
would be having this much conversation
on Twitter without Game Pass not even
remotely I agree you give people so many
and the fact that so many people are bad
because they can't be the first boss
yeah and they're dropping it right but
it shows me how people never would have
bought it exactly how many people jumped
in that would have never jumped in
that's the key and even team ninja has
said that but yeah I was gonna say uh
and imagine the people that do like Wu
long that's never played a sales game
that's like yo like newer audience
people getting into the the ecosystem in
general and they're like you know I like
this then what are they doing they're
going back well let me try secure let me
try bloodborne let me try
that's how it starts and you already
yeah and you're already in a system that
has these other games that can be a
gateway to others but then we got this
uh Resident Evil demo attic
last yeah
so if you can you can uh
we both played it I played Alex played
it more than me all we all played okay
it was zero dollars
it was beta boy at other places people
are paying for the demo a word yeah word
oh I even don't have that now
I could not wait for this because they
was paying 20 cents and I think
Microsoft was like two dollars in in New
Zealand or something
that's the best source
so what are you guys thinking again I
decided to play because I was like okay
it's only the village part and for me I
just really wanted I had recently been
playing
four again just to kind of get a feel
for it kind of to see where it needed to
sort of change and grow a little bit and
I'll be honest what I played so far is
is is very close to what we had before
it's just considerably prettier right
um they made some changes that some
people may like something may not like
um I don't know how you guys feel about
the Parry oh yeah the Parry is something
that I you know if you're good at
pairing you it's it makes you super
powerful because you're pushing back
people all the time right including like
big bosses so
um that's that's gonna be important it's
crazy you can Parry chainsaw
with a knife but wow what I think what I
think they got right is re4 was that
game that that kind of crossed that line
from just pure horror and what the way
it it expressed hard through action
right was the fact that Leon Kennedy in
this game was super like he's a he's a
hyped up kind of super soldier right
he's strong he isn't Leon Kennedy from
the original you know re2 so he's
skilled and so how do you how do you
create dread how do you create fear well
they put you in a village with people
that are coming at you from all kinds of
angles right it's the this idea of being
overwhelmed by these horrific
circumstances and I think in this game
in this version it feels like they
really got that down because at this
time the gennados look more realistic
chainsaw dude looks crazy
and the fact they come at you from every
window every door every single pause
orifice
and and the fact that you know that you
see him trying to dodge and win the only
thing that I is again I don't know how
the final product is it just feels like
there aren't enough animations for all
the stuff that he's doing now like there
isn't like oh this is the same animation
over and over right it is not a weave
animation for one day
you kind of stumble out of situation
sometimes when you counter somebody you
should be able to sort of get out of the
way with somebody else attacking you
because guaranteed somebody's attacking
you from behind from the sides and a lot
of that doesn't feel like it was
considered in this so they they stuck
very close to the original and that
where some of that feels a little bit
old it's just super pretty now
um but all in all I'm excited for what's
there because I know they've made other
changes is this little Village Park just
gave me a little taste of you know what
what to kind of expect a little
disappointed in some of the control
stuff but not crazy we'll see how the
discourse around the knife countering
goes
um but yeah excited overall and it's
pretty it's very pretty oh it's
beautiful attic she gay man this year
Resident Evil Goat right
yeah well resonate before is definitely
my favorite Resident Evil and it's just
for you know variety of reasons I felt
like it you know it's a solid story I
think it did a lot of things that kind
of moved the entire gaming industry
forward you got games like Dead Space
that spawned out of nowhere because this
game's like Resident Evil they've
literally said that they wouldn't have
made that game the way they did without
Resident Evil 4 being a factor
um I like what they're doing here I
think Capcom is a prime example that
they have redefined what the word remake
is and they pretty much coming out and
they're like look like we took we took a
huge Risk by making Resident Evil 2 way
more than we had to and I think that
because you know obviously people have a
little issue of Resident Evil 3 but
because they did that and they're taking
these remakes seriously I feel like
the next game's doing better than the
previous game because even though people
had an issue with Resident Evil 3 to a
lot of degrees everyone loved those
games everyone loved the attention they
took did everyone loved the fact that
they made remakes and I have to
obviously give Final Fantasy 7 flowers
too because they're doing it too and
it's just like they're coming out there
and these companies are showing you like
look you could sell these old games and
make just as much money as newer games
you just have to actually invest and
commit to it you can't just sit here
come out there and like yo we go we're
going we're going to sprinkle some some
graphics we're gonna sprinkle some FPS
and then it's like and then final
product and then it's like you know now
give us 60 bucks then the game bombs and
they're like okay no one wants remasters
remakes no people have no problem
investing into a brand that they've
already played years ago people have a
problem the bare minimum doing it and
then not getting what they feel is out
because some of these remember Sleeping
Dogs dogs like remastered for the Xbox
One and PS4 it was 60 dollars for pretty
much just uh like a small graphic
enhancement in some of the DLC like
people don't want that they want solid
remake experiences and as long as you do
that you actually can get good results
so you know I'm liking them because you
look at something like Fable you know if
they do remake Fable one to uh had a lot
let's say that they've been doing that
in the past like I'm hoping these
companies look in these older IPS and
they're like look we can make money
let's just invest a little bit more
money so we could actually put our best
foot forward and I like games like this
I know that doesn't really have a lot to
do with resident before but it it's I
like the fact that you're seeing this
trend go up and not just Resident Evil 2
that just goes down no one else does it
and it's rezzy before shows he's like
look we got Resident Evil floors out
structure
got the foundation built now let's take
that that 90s approach you know that the
old grandma Grandma's sofas no one likes
anymore let's get rid of all that we
let's let's get rid of the 1980s
refrigerator let's put a modern
refrigerator in there let's actually
take our time and make this house look
modern and I got to get a officer like
it's like you can look at something like
Resident Evil 4 even if you played that
game I suggest you buy that yeah I
played it even if even if you go out and
you look at you never play resident
before go buy that because I have always
been a a prominent person on
rewarding good behavior oh for sure
doing good behavior
King we down with the Resident Evil
remake what we doing well you got us um
you got to think uh Sony
Microsoft
um didn't help him out with uh Street
Fighter and they were at a pivotal uh a
moment right and then you had the
remakes come after the street fighter
got you know bankrolled and they made
some bread off of that and they were
able to go into two different
um directions
you were able to go into the the new
Resident Evil games where they went
first person which was highly successful
and then they went back and they did
remakes and their remakes
were from the ground up yes right so it
wasn't okay the same thing because they
did it before they they gave you
enhancements of Resident Evil Resident
Evil again and then resonate evil remake
and then you finally got the remasters
the Resident Evil 2 remastered was like
crazy and then Resident Evil 3 was
insane but we all know the reason for
you to own a GameCube was for this
Resident Evil 4 right and when it came
out it changed the game Charlotte's
never looked it's good that's right so
when we got the and you saw the Sherling
moving at the bottom he was like oh and
then he pulled out the gun and and you
know and they was like la migrada
what's up
exactly not Mexican sir
yes yes yes
so when I was like oh they went Hispanic
with it
I'm like oh the virus is in Ecuador
hello
real quick there is a a poll in the chat
I want to hear you guys uh input on that
continue so
this is uh being that this was probably
the turning point with Capcom uh where
they really put the best graphical foot
forward because at this point in time
Resident Evil 4 was all the the best
yeah that was the ball oh yeah
for them to get back to this I didn't
play the demo I'm going to play the you
know some games with us
work what else okay now nope nope I
still ain't even played my Resident Evil
2 all the way didn't even do three but
I'm buying four like a fool uh this is
this is how you make backlogs for games
that you never play
um
that you have Nostalgia for this is how
to capitalize on yes yes
um but I do actually this is yo I
remember when the haircut yeah
the GameCube was a monster that power PC
yeah that was inside there that little
guy was a monster I never felt proud to
take that little purple little Satchel
handbag with me
uh to play uh at no points this this was
the best game I I have high expectations
for this game but I do say this
high in the hierarchy of Capcom the
decisions that were made and monies that
were allocated to further grow the
business and to like hunker down because
they were looking at acquisition being
an acquisition they was looking at
probably going away it was looking at a
lot of uh a downside and they just did a
180. they did a complete 180 it started
with the street fighter it ran itself
over to these remakes and it's still
taking the Resident Evil because
Resident Evil 8
is this is the same company that's
giving you quality stuff Resident Evil 8
they're giving you quality vrs because
they add the VR yeah yeah
right they're not saying yo oh we got VR
in here we're gonna charge you money
Dave VR is in there if you happen to
have it you can do this right and then
they giving you remakes and they are
pushing the the genre forward for
remakes they're the high water marks for
remake so
I think it's going to do well very well
now I didn't play a like an hour or two
of it and I'll just blow it away I just
man this looks phenomenal like I just
the light source and the tension I
always like the over the shoulder with
the camera Joy you know what I'm saying
I'm just seeing the cinematics now
seeing the details on the enemies it
hits different I feel like I get more
what what
I put in the thing I said where'd you
hear the Lords from and uh I learned I
learned from the iron Lords because my
ex-boyfriend told me about that
shout out to the ex-boyfriend
yeah no I just it just brought back the
field it it it it gives you the
appreciation of it with more of a today
modern feel and it looks good it looks
bad and look I'm Leon Kennedy all day I
I feel he's always in the best Resident
Evil so I'm just saying you know I like
this other guy that you know there's a
steroid guy
I was so disappointed with six because
it was the first time they brought all
them together in that kind of
ways do you think that there's enough
good game in six story-wise whatever the
case to remake it
I want them to redo five and add on to
like they did four but then when it
comes to six I just want them to redo
that whole kit yeah I want I want to
kick I want Veronica
Dreamcast Veronica for some reason five
was one of the most sold Resident Evils
I highly doubt their next game
no you know what I think you'll
eventually get Veronica I just think
they're gonna you know what if they know
they can make the whole thing about five
is the thing about five is five five
great Co-op game it was it was more
action game than it was horror the the
thinking and conversation around it now
is that it has some troubling uh
depictions of racism
when they had the yellow eyes and the
yellow teeth yeah yes
I said if they didn't get Pookie to
crackhead
are you implied that they can't be
attacking certain races yo listen thank
you
it's like they take three people they
scan and they're okay let's put this one
yeah
save three crackheads but I didn't get
outraged all right because nobody kid
when in it was uh Hillbillies nobody
that was actually free as hell nobody
cared when it was infected whites in the
beginning right then when they went to
Spanish dude was just like do you know
your eyes
right and this is I got to call my
people out on this y'all want to be
sensitive but y'all don't want to be
inclusive nah then they went to Africa
y'all was like nah this is racist no
it's not racism man it's a subject
everybody getting something everybody
I I will say I think it's poorly
researched yeah if anything I I wouldn't
say it's like race it's just poorly
research I don't care where they do it
whatever it was unintentionally I want
you indigenous people to be zombies yeah
so I'm down for I don't care it would it
would look like disgusting
with Grace I was okay babe just when we
do okay like I ain't gonna fight with
you on ammo so I'm a rocker infinity
ammo okay you you gonna play like Norm
no what I didn't like when the zombies
are shooting
but when the zombies
tell me how Grace had the basic handgun
and I'm rolling over there with the
infinity
like the Infinity uh
what I was doing I was just sitting back
and I'm just letting her try to kill
them and after like enough of them came
around I was like all right
you still got two left
anyways so that's all I have I like I
like my racism equal opportunity
listen if if I go to Jamaica I expect to
see Jamaican
pretty much find the city of Atlantis
zombies
let's get them out of here
we'll definitely be playing this uh it
comes out the Friday they wear packs so
it's gonna be oh yeah we got a lot of
stuff oh yes speaking of packs first of
all I want to like to appreciate
everybody that got the Volari pillows
these things is shipping so everybody
that did purchase this shipping um I
gotta send out some links to a couple of
people because I was I talked to a
couple of guys and they didn't know that
we were selling pillows if it's the
first time that you found us
um these valari pillows
have our uh logo on it uh you know
Volari right here in conjunction with
Volare the stitching is crazy
IOP here it connects in the back of you
and you put it around your waist while
you're playing like if you saw me
sitting right here my elbows was locked
in and I was uh you know talking my back
wasn't hurting Everything feels really
good this is the same gaming posture
that I have when I'm playing my video
games so uh it's a premium quality
product link is in the description box
exactly it was lowered 15 at the chat
get 50 so like I want to explain if
purchase it does go in factor into our
road to Pax right but we can't update it
right now because of how
um the the program works but all the
super chats go in there and uh when you
buy uh Teespring stuff all that stuff
going and so I do appreciate everybody
helping us go to packs yes we only have
two more weekends yeah in the next week
and that's it uh so this weekend is up
and next weekend and we have um uh R and
R with the law and also any Lords that's
going to be at PAX East pull up pull up
because like I said we have something
pop up the shirt potentially yeah please
it's it's it's we're trying to to finish
off this this These Bars it looks it's
looking like kind of tight like I don't
know if we're gonna make it I hope we do
because we want to do something the road
to packs has a special thing for
everybody that's there yes and we're
trying our best to make that happen
no doubt they went Batman without fear
we got you they're still coming about to
make announcements on exact shipping all
that good stuff we got you I'll get the
poll now solve it while you get the
super chance and then okay with the
latest delay of Starfield falling out of
the next 12 months decree from 22 to
2022's Xbox and Bethesda showcase which
to you is most important a Xbox stop
over promising and under delivering your
word should mean something God oh God
B starfield's quality and polish should
be the number one priority as Xbox most
important exclusive since Halo that's
right or C I don't care Starfield is
doomed God Howard did not wear the brown
leather during the launch date
announcement
shout out to the chat it was gonna be up
on IOP Twitter go check that out at iron
Lord podcast and of course the amazing
Chris ray gun was in a building rocked
with us while long had mad fun salute
salute salute I mean it's not Atticus so
always get these uh Super Chat sir bet
and like King was saying also uh yeah I
put the the link in the chat once again
hit that joinhoney.com
join honey.com slash Iron Lords that
will help your people yeah we ain't even
getting paid for that one man yeah
just do it like and it comes down you
know something at it somebody told me
they like they put on Twitter
um I got to do uh something you know uh
because they for some weird reason they
think likes equal payment right yeah
like like we get paid listen and I'm
Gonna Keep it a hundred with you guys
everything that goes into this podcast
comes and goes right back you see a mic
go look at our earliest stuff factual
the cameras the mic
um I think what it is King people don't
realize how much this stuff costs this
might just this mic is 400 yep just the
mic this is I remember when it was like
yeah
everybody here has a job like so if you
see these statues or whatever this was
before the podcast he's going in our
pockets doing that we don't let's with
the camera alone that we're doing the
podcast off is over a thousand so like
we put everything back into the show
we're supposed to look for sponsors
we're supposed to look for some type of
help right you guys are the fuel to be
honest with you for us to get to that
help nah King stop having you supposed
to give me all this for free I don't
like you talking about it
we're one of the only podcasts that goes
to all these of Live Events
you supposed to go to the events how I
say and you're supposed to sit here for
five hours and give me free stuff
we don't normally we don't normally get
into like it costs 900 just for the
flight yo let me tell you something
that's disgusting and disrespectful it
used to be 300 it was pure with bro
no no no no this I just want you to
always asking me for something now we're
not rich bro we don't know man so please
go out
people say did the money go to the
trench coat no it's missing two buttons
it's like a premium trench coat okay
why you think I got the hoodie on cause
I gotta go to work
the King has spoken exactly he's not
working he's not working
oh sorry super chances
okay uh Nova 30 and 13 13 months I
remember 13 months Lord bronze
pixel Primal features many dinosaurs
players will get to battle Jim Ryan
how's that the game description
I'm done then we got Dragonheart Yogi
once again one year I remember for one
year five dollars content oh boy gonna
pop up with a thong on that says my
sovereign
[Laughter]
he's gonna come in as a [__] oh boy
yeah
why don't you play with my joystick
slow
why don't we play with each other
we gotta cut your mic off sir you're
doing way too much way too much why I
gotta have a help
the way we do it down here
yeah
right here
all right we got to get him together we
gotta get it together yeah I'm sorry
and we got free R Kelly Two Dollars of
attack Resident Evil 4 remake Game of
the Year 2023.
hey you got that homie hi I'm sales two
dollar Super Chat you guys are the best
actors
is fortnite on be ready Monday
then we got Grill night two dollars we
chat first time watching live excited to
be here but let's put the crust in the
chat for the very first Super Chat from
girl night appreciation thank you thank
you everything goes right back in
then we got Nintendo taco no he said if
Saul's wife knew what was coming
he's actually these
I certainly hope so something Spanish
that look wild for I don't know what he
wrote it's bad
this is her version of flirting with
some like Loki
elevatory
do get a shirt that has nothing but that
new super chats all over
sitting down playing video games with a
uh Atari joystick continue
all right we have let me see let me see
depend on the old Taco
stupid chat no more Resident Evil remake
Mega Man Legends
Battle Network so we'll see about
Legends Battle Network oh so look at
that mod gaming in the show and they
should say pull up on me
you're doing too much
we
had delegating sponsors again ever again
foreign
and even the people not you know can't
do it financially you show up here give
us numbers give us likes like you don't
remember you don't realize just the
numbers of the podcast alone can help us
get these phones yo um and I keep
telling y'all if we can get to 15 000
subscribers because we got to 14. yeah
get the 15 000 subscribers we're gonna
give away a PlayStation 5. let's [__]
let's let's continue
there we have hi I'm cells again two
dollars which I wish I can give more at
spot whatever just being here is enough
with people just just making those likes
above 500 though man let's do that let's
get those likes about 500. getting down
sites you know fortnite let's go
there we have Tai casares three dollar
Super Chat have a great day Lords you as
well brother appreciation I appreciate
you we are caught up here yeah let's get
out of here yep great show everybody
everybody got anything the same before
we go now you ain't got you answer your
thing right there on Tuesday at 5 PM
where I'll be talking about the movie uh
65.
um it's a longer uh title when you see
the movie you want to talk about it uh
we're gonna talk about
um what's that movie you saw at it Jesus
Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ came out uh
scream six oh so you saw Scream Six and
I saw operation Fortune so we'll be
talking about that in the last of us uh
we might sprinkle in a little bit of
Mandalorian and I'm going to be doing my
Attack on Titan uh catching up on that
so and uh yeah and I think the season
finale of um
reacts tomorrow I will say this is the
week to tune into our little podcast at
Lords of gaming.net can't say too much
else but we got some stuff really
cooking this week and I'm excited to
talk about that well we can you know
what I'm saying some stuff a little
further actually some of the stuff can't
be till week after yeah yeah yeah
but yeah we got some really really might
be able to show pictures yes yes we can
yes we can so we got some really dope
stuff cooking and I'm super excited
about again like King was saying and we
joke and everything but every little
thing helps every little thing we are
trying to grow this thing bigger and
better do more things like that and we
always give it back put it right back in
and y'all go see it y'all go see it this
year I can't wait I'm excited so but we
appreciate the love oh another one came
in and we could have been yeah I got
pragmatic Eagle five dollar Super Chat
the fact that y'all can keep us here for
five plus hours proves y'all the goats
of podcasting much much love the fact
that you guys can keep me here for five
hours my wife disagrees but you know
I hope he's coming to Game Pass
I'm like yeah or more so anyway that's
it that's all I got everybody enjoy your
Sunday I think we good yeah we good man
it's yeah it's like I said patreon uh
King's reactions happening tomorrow for
the season finale of Attack on Titan or
the one before that I can't remember and
I think my season finale of Chainsaw man
is next week too no doubt hey guys I'm
on patreon catch y'all another big week
next week see y'all
real quick go back real quick go back
real quick I'm sorry oh my God we back
what happened you know I'm sorry I've
said to you guys to some dude named
Bozard someone's following on on YouTube
I don't know who he is he got six
followers
that's the homie yeah I'm sending you
guys over there I'm going to tell them
IOP systems
I bet you you guys gonna blow his mind
going yeah
thank you
[Music]
foreign